free will ultimately does not come in
until there's some awareness in you
that's where Free Will comes from until
you have some awareness you are run by
the conditioning of your mind and so you
have no choice the element of choice
comes in when you become aware for
example of your the thoughts that go
through your head and you might realize
suddenly and for some people that's the
first time they awaken spiritually when
they realize that for years they've had
a voice in their head talking to them
which could be a monologue it could be a
dialogue you could have a conversation
with yourself you can beat yourself up
and say I'm not good enough the voice in
the head for some people the spiritual
awakening comes when they become aware
that there's a voice in the head and
there's the awareness at the moment
that's the awareness you might even be
able to choose to let go of a certain
thought a repetitive thought that you
don't need anymore that you don't want
anymore and then you you surrender it or
you breathe it out you don't need it hey
seven Carmichael and I make these videos
because running the business is hard and
waking up every day and getting to work
when you're all by yourself is hard and
the thing that saved me that continues
to inspire me motivate me give me hope
inspiration ideas is looking at the
stories of people who've done a lot more
than me and I learn strategies I get
motivation and it gets me to believe in
myself to go off and attack the day and
so I hope this video inspires you to do
the same as well so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Eckhart Tolle enjoy
but sometimes people's on the grip of
strong emotions but if there's a little
bit of awareness there if at let's say
it's anger you're suddenly anger arises
but in the background you're aware that
this emotion of anger so there's a small
element of choices come in do you want
to then attack this person if there's
awareness you can observe the anger but
made no longer men no longer need to act
it out
I'm not talking about suppressing but
recognizing the more awareness you have
or presence the more choices in your
life and then it's only then that you
actually become truly intelligent
because this awareness is not an IQ
thing the way you can have
I've met highly intelligent people with
one or two or three phds
academics and others we are completely
unconscious completely unaware still
just completely in their minds and and
people
in their personal lives often very
dysfunctional personal lives so it's not
to be equated with intelligence this
awareness to take a responsibility for
what is it that you can take
responsibility for primarily
it's taking responsibility for your
state of consciousness
which
determines
what kind of world you create
you because you are Humanity
humanity is an abstract concept doesn't
exist humanity is the human being
you are Humanity so for Humanity
to take responsibility you need to take
primarily responsibility for your State
of Consciousness because only a diseased
or dysfunctional State of Consciousness
produces a diseased and dysfunctional
world out there
by world I mean the human-made world
that is has been imposed on the what's
already there the planet which is
potentially of course a paradise
the planet
pristine unbelievable Jewel
a being of great intelligence
we are not separate from it
but the being is going through a
transitional process
and every transitional process is
critical it may or may not work in which
case the being will
go or some other way
but the
the
your State of Consciousness determines
what kind of world you create what kind
of
action you take and what consequences
your actions have
so here
this is why my main work is to address
the cause of
dysfunction which lies in the human mind
the dysfunction of the human mind or as
it is sometimes called in Zen the
sickness of the human mind
so
as I see it and I don't
think anybody who reads history can
doubt it there is a deep-seated
dysfunction in humans has been there for
thousands of years
and
if we're not
if there's no shift in that then the
dysfunction will destroy us
it probably won't destroy the planet
because the planet has enormous
resources but it will take a while it
would take a while for the planet to
recover
all you have to do then is primarily
take responsibility for your State of
Consciousness now
now
and this is what the entire teaching
really is about what is what is my state
of consciousness at this moment am I
generating
disturbance am I generating
negativity am I generating conflict and
suffering for myself and others
am I generating inner pollution am I
polluting my beautiful the beautiful
being that I am
with continuous
absurd
movements of thought producing
negative emotions producing an entire
entity
that is illusory that I call the me
so to take responsibility it needs to be
just of course an Awakening where you
can say okay I will take responsibility
now
some people don't know that there is
even the possibility of taking
responsibility that's why you are so
important
anybody who realizes it
this is you are the beginning of the
transformed world most of the time there
is a voice in your head that comments
and has opinions and viewpoints and
interpretations about what's going on in
your life I call that the voice in the
head
for most humans that is completely
involuntary
they don't even know that they have a
voice in the head that never stops
talking
most of the time
and silently in your head at other times
it may even sort something out so it
wants to be heard
and so if you walk in the street you
will find most people look fairly sane
they're not talking to themselves it
seems because they're not talking out
aloud but if you listened into
everybody's head you would be amazed of
how noisy
the inside of every human is
it's like a raid you know these radio
stations where the the people talk in an
excited voice they go on and on if you
go to a foreign country and you don't
know what they're talking about you
might think this must be extremely
important
but if you can understand what they are
saying you realize it's it's completely
meaningless it's just noise
so a significant part of what happens in
your mind the larger part is actually
just Superfluous noise
this thinking is a wonderful ability a
wonderful tool if you used rightly it is
an instrument that causes
dysfunction and misery for Millions on
the planet
unhappiness for Millions on the planet
if thinking is not used but if you are
used by thought
so when humans say I think in most cases
that's actually not true because they
have no control over their thinking it's
a compulsive and involuntary and they
are so identified with these thought
processes they don't even know that they
are in the grip of their thought
processes because they are so identified
they become their thought processes so
whatever comes into your head you
completely believe in it and then you
yeah that's how it is whenever you feel
unhappiness this is a generic term
unhappiness in whatever form unhappiness
can arise as irritation can arise as
anger can arise as even
boredom is a form of unhappiness
sadness
all kinds of states it doesn't they
don't feel Pleasant they do unhappiness
and usually they are attributed to life
situation something that's going on in
your life
it looks so for example sort of waiting
at the airline counter and of course how
often things don't go well there
uh let's hope they don't drag you out of
the plane but it'll that could that
could happen too
Rising anger Rising upset in whatever
form ask yourself
is this caused by the situation
or is it caused by what my mind is
telling me about the situation and in 95
percent of cases
you will find that the mental commentary
that argues and complains about
something that's going on but should not
be going on but it is
but shouldn't be and the gap between
what is and what the mind says should be
or should not be
that Gap is the rising of unhappiness
and misery
or is the Buddha called suffering a
powerful
transformation can happen when you and
this is one way of approaching it which
may be helpful to you
uh is
not
to desire
any
thing within you
to be different from the way it is now
so that would mean
complete acceptance of whatever it is
that you experience at any given moment
at the moment there are these energies
in you but
you don't really want them so there is a
there's a conflict in what you want and
what you have
now if you approach it in a different
way instead of hanging what you want you
perhaps you want Stillness you want
peace you want that deeper sense of
aliveness perhaps that's the yearning
you want to be fully yourself
and what you have is you perhaps you
feel contraction in the body you feel
excessive mind activity you feel and at
almost
semi-physical energy field blocking
you
so you have the two you have what you
want and you have what you have
now as a practice I suggest that
you do away with a conflict between what
you have and what you want
and you want what you have
instead which means whatever your inner
reality or outer reality but we're
talking mainly about inner now
whatever your inner reality is right now
as it's always now of course not it's
not a big thing it's only the reality
now
accept it it's totally this is this is
what it is and so bring that acceptance
is a strange thing when you really can
say well that's what it is you might as
well accept it because it it is the
reality of this moment
so if you bring that exception through
no matter even it feels not pleasant if
it might be a contraction in the body or
my mind is just so active Okay let my
mind be active
bring in bring the allowing to it and
that the strange thing happens you may
find
when you do it you you it will already
be have a little bit of space around the
condition that you dislike but now you
accept
and so you accept the condition that you
previously disliked but now you say well
that's what is
so I allow it to be
and what you then Skin Sense if you're
inside of you a little bit of space
around the condition
so not much and Trust just a little bit
so let's say you have a contraction here
and say that's what is
and this acceptance
brings space so here's the trash and
then he have a little bit of hence what
is
and then
it may grow a little bit this space
around it
and then you find
[Music]
you become more interested in that
little space around it than in the
condition
so you give more attention to that the
spaciousness that around that comes with
the acceptance
of what is and you can sense that space
a bit more
and then it's what I'm saying is not
literally true but I'm just saying it
grows it seems to grow and then there's
a bit more the street condition is still
the same but it has a receded somewhat
it's no longer the center of your
attention you that you're more aware of
the space you become the space right
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there I had a very extremely painful
relationship with myself
I couldn't live with myself anymore
and so I
somehow said that's it
I can't live with it anymore that's it
but that was so total
that I no longer
sustained
fueled the self through thought I didn't
know anything about it it just happened
so the Mind Made image dissolved
the self that I couldn't live with that
was so
heavy
dissolved
and what was left was simply
I
so the I saved it from whereas before
when I said I I was referring to myself
the unhappy dense eye the story-based
eye
that dissolved and then the true
I
emerged had always been there
presence
I am
[Music]
nothing in particular anymore a simple
sense of presence or beingness
foreign
and be without having a relationship
with myself
and that there is something
so precious in that
eye or presence
so
it's beyond words you could say it's
like a diamond it's something extremely
very very precious that's why perhaps
Buddhism sometimes has the image of a
diamond
but this is not comparative
it's not a sense of
that deepest self not the Mind Made
itself
is so precious that it has
it knows itself to be that in a
non-dualistic
Why without needing to compare itself to
others it has nothing to do with the
form
or any mind form
so as presence arises
you don't need
self-esteem anymore you don't depend on
that anymore
because what dissolves is the Mind Made
entity with which you have a
relationship
and it's so self-esteem is an
intermediate thing that for a little
while makes your life more pleasant
fine
and then
after a while you see the unsatisfactory
nature even of that because you cannot
uphold continuous
self-esteem it's hard work
all these affirmations
and then things come into your life that
tell you the opposite
inevitably sooner or later
so
then suddenly you don't love yourself
anymore nor do you hate yourself because
there's no self to love they're simply
the state of this which is love
it emanates I often say say yes to the
present moment
or I say make the present moment your
friend not your enemy
so it's a to say yes to the present
moment is a powerful teaching but it can
be misunderstood and has been
misunderstood sometimes and it needs to
be explained what that actually means it
means
um oh by the way um
there's a funny movie made a few if some
years ago with Jim Carrey it's called
the Yes Man
and this is a person in the movie a
character the character he plays
he works at a bank I think to in the
mortgage department and he's very he's
very bitter and he likes to say no to
people who apply for mortgages every no
you can't have any Lovesick and it's
very negative about everything now his
life is
the uneventful boring is everything is
negative then he goes to a new age
a friend invites him to a strange New
Age event with a new age teacher and the
teacher says you have to say yes
to everything say yes to everything and
he kind of
becomes convinced well I might as well
try that I've got nothing to lose
and from then on whatever people ask him
every mortgage he approves and whatever
people ask him can you lend me money
sure yes can you do this yes yes yes yes
and then his life becomes very
interesting but also very chaotic he
gets into most chaotic situations and he
kind of all gets out of hand and
I
and in the end he kind of seems to
realize that this wasn't quite working
it's that that was that is not the true
meaning
so to say yes to the present moment does
not mean that you accept everything that
people ask of you
in some cases you have to use the now
the no
but in the
um non but not
in an angry way that denies the present
moment I call that
a high quality no
so it's let's say
um in the office can you look after my
children or let's speak and because I I
need your yourself so good with children
the seal flatter you do you feel obliged
you're such a wonderful person I say I
love you can you do it again please and
at some point safety I'm sorry I can't
do it anymore
um but without
any negativity a simple statement it is
not a reactive statement you don't make
her into a bad person I know she you
want to take advantage of me I'm not
doing it anymore this is a low quality
now
even if perhaps you she did try to
perhaps she was trying to take advantage
of you but that is not that maybe then a
dysfunction in her egoic self many
humans do that the world is full of
people who perhaps are trying to take
advantage of you that's what the egos do
and so it is not who she truly is but
you speak to you you do not speak to the
ego in her you simply say
I love your children they're just
wonderful and I enjoyed my time but I
can't do it anymore I'm sorry about that
high quality no no no I can't do that a
person says can you lend me another
thousand dollars
um and you do well I've already lent you
2 000 three months ago and last year I
lent you five thousand I haven't got
anything back yet
and then it's I'm sorry I have to say no
but you don't say
did you just you're just trying to use
me
and I'm not going to do that anymore I'm
not going to be used anymore by you this
is it that's it I know more that that's
another kind of no but it's a low
quality no
and the high qualities no I'm sorry
that's it I can't do that anymore this
it it reply it implies there's a
presence behind what you say it's not
reactive
and with the same the person who asked
you to write something you say I've seen
the background I'm not in agreement with
that therefore I'm sorry I need to say
no to this I can't do this thank you
high quality knobs it's beautiful and it
works quite often you may have to use
that make sure that it's not reactive
and then becomes low quality when I
meditate
a stream fear often arises in my mind I
feel like I would be destroyed or
completely disappeared so I stopped
meditation because of the fear I'm so
afraid to keep going on although I
intuitively know that bearing the fear
would get me closer to Enlightenment how
can I conquer this fear
this is yes of course the fear of the
person the personalized sense of self or
the ego
which can feel
threatened
by the arising awareness and once you
know that
you can still meditate and allow the
fear to be there it's only when you try
to run away from the fear that really it
becomes a great obstacle
but if you can be with the fear allow
the fear to be there as on a pure energy
level Feel the fear
then
you will find it begins to dissolve
so rather than not wanting to feel it
allow yourself to feel it
then this is the beginning of change
if you always run away from it
then
it will linger there's no change
there's a book called think feel the
fear and do it anyway or something like
that but that is a quite good advice
although I mean not applied necessarily
to everything
I'm going to jump off now
but to allow yourself to feel whatever
feeling comes is part of the present the
what the is-ness of the present moment
so if the fear Rises but then you also
realize what is is the fear created by a
thought you will know that or is the
fear arising just by itself in a
particular situation when you become
still
do you have a fear of Silence do you
feel uncomfortable when you go into a
room and there's there's no noise in it
some people do feel some people are
uncomfortable in nature
it's not noisy enough
so see it may be that the fear arises
when you when you become still you
meditate then it's not necessarily
associated with the thought but with
that arising of awareness and instead of
British
stopping your meditation
just what happens if I just carry on and
make the fear into a meditation meditate
on the fear so in when if you do
meditate
nothing really can disturb you with the
good meditator
incorporates whatever arises in the
present moment into the meditation
including the most irritating noise that
suddenly starts up outside
and the mind says I can't meditate now
I need Stillness and then you realize no
perhaps this is part of the meditation
and how does it become part of the
meditation
by allowing the isness of this moment
which is that by just letting go of
resistance allow whatever it is to be
and if it comes from within
fear anxiety you allow that to be but
you have to be careful that it doesn't
become a thought
because the moment you are drawn back
into thinking that's the end of your
meditation
you can allow a thought to be there but
to order to allow a soul to be there
that that
implies that there is some awareness
there
behind the thoughts or you are still
if so to be able it's a wonderful thing
do you allow the thought to be that's
very different from being drawn into the
thought and following it where it wants
to take you of course that's the end of
your meditation or your mindfulness or
whatever you want to call it I don't use
mindfulness as you know because
it's not about a full mind
that's why I avoid the word mindfulness
but mindfulness is a lovely thing it's
really its presence
so you can follow a sword it takes it
grabs you it grabs all your attention
and pulls you along that's one way
or you can realize there's a thought
arising about
what my ex-spouse did five years ago to
me
while I'm meditating
and you can allow the thoughts to arise
instantly be aware and if you do that
instead of being pulled into it then you
will find that it quickly it arises and
it subsides so then it becomes very much
like you know the sky
it was on let's say you have a blue sky
and clouds occasionally come so the
clouds are the thoughts that arise in
the mind
the blue skies the vastness of that
space is your awareness
so clouds are not a problem if
within the larger context of the aware
presence
they come and go and they might be
thoughts that say ridiculous things
there might be a thought about
I'd like to eat a
apple pie now I really need to eat apple
pie the mica is the most absurd things
to interrupt your meditation
can you imagine an apple pie you're
eating
and then you know there's the thought of
apple pie you allow that to be you don't
get drawn into the apple pie salt or
even suddenly you have to get up and run
to the fridge to see if there's an apple
pie is still in there
a later the thought arises you are the
sky that's the awareness
and the thought is what comes into the
awareness now if more and more thoughts
come
or if you follow one of the cloud
thoughts that drift into the space of
awareness one of the cloud thoughts and
she suddenly go it it it grabs hold of
you and you follow it and the cloud gets
bigger
then it attracts other clouds that
correspond to it they suddenly come from
out of nowhere
and then you are in a big cloud you're
still sitting there trying to meditate
but you're really in a big cloud of
thought
and before you know it
the entire sky is
cloudy all totally overcast
now of course there's still some light
shining through the clouds but you'd no
longer know where that comes from
there's some light of of course
Consciousness sword cannot exist without
Consciousness thought is a manifestation
of consciousness
but so there's the Consciousness that is
behind the thoughts but you don't no
longer know that Consciousness directly
only through the filter of thoughts in
the same way that you don't know the
sunlight anymore except through the
filter of the clouds I'm surprised
there's nothing on Google about Eckhart
and free will but maybe maybe I haven't
said anything about it
uh
so here we go
as you know it's an it's an eternal
ancient philosophical question and
there's never been a definitive answer
but that everybody would agree with in
that sense
so is there Australian you mentioned
everybody is doing their best because
every nobody can act beyond their level
of Consciousness etc for example
okay let's start from on one level
uh
and then we go on to the next level
on on the level of egoic
unconsciousness where you are a
conditioned entity your your mental
emotional makeup extra totally
conditioned by the past and you are
completely identified with the
conditioning of your of your mind
and in that state that spiritually
speaking is the unconscious state it is
obvious that in that state there is no
Freedom at all because because you are
forced to act out the unconscious
conditioning of your mind with which you
are completely identified
so I think most people would probably
agree if you understand
that that on that level
there is no possibility of Freedom their
actions are determined by the
unconditioned mind you are forced to act
as you do because there's no choice
because choice would imply some
awareness
so on that level there's certainly no
freedom
then
awareness comes in the human being
begins to awaken
then it appears I'm not saying it is the
case
it appears that then the human the free
Freedom
begins to be a possibility because
you can
choose
to step out of the conditioning of your
mind you can recognize a conditioned
thought
and do you are no longer compelled to
act it out because there is an awareness
there you can choose a certain cause of
action not not from the conditioning of
your mind but from the the presence so
you can you can you can act and you have
much more freedom that before you could
not have freedom comes with
awareness
so it's then relative to the unconscious
day there is now freedom to act
but
if you look more deeply even there
even there on that level you are
connected with the totality of
Consciousness you're only an expression
of the totality of Consciousness you are
not really a separate entity you are a
like a esposited you are was it Alan
Watts who said you are you in the same
way that the the wave is something that
the ocean is doing
you are something that the whole
universe is doing in the same same way
so the wave is something the ocean is
doing you are something that the
universe is doing
so although it appears from a certain
relative to the previous state of
unconsciousness there is freedom and
relative to that there is freedom but
then if you look more deeply into that
you realize that even there one cannot
say that you are choosing this speak you
are an expression of Consciousness and
Consciousness one could say is choosing
and you think you're doing it sometimes
people ask me can you choose to be
present uh and you know from one
perspective you can choose to be present
from another perspective
one could say that the presence chooses
you it chooses to become present through
you depends how you look at it uh so in
Ultimate terms or the in relative terms
there is freedom relative to the
unconscious State when you become more
conscious but even there it's only
relative to the unconscious State even
there there is no not absolute freedom
because you do not exist as an
independent entity you have a part of
the web of interconnectedness that is
the whole universe so in that sense
there is no freedom of choice of the
individual because ultimately there is
no individual so to
to go about wanting to manifest material
abundance in your life is perhaps not
the
the right way to go about it
because you're concentrating on the
outermost layer of abundance
and even if you manage to manifest
abundance on the outer level
it's not going to
give you the true feeling of abundance
it's not in other words it's not going
to make you happy
it's not going to fulfill you except for
a few days
the new possession nice and shiny
whatever it is and there you look at it
got it now it's my
and after a few days or a week or two
or give it a month
it wears off
hmm
it's no longer that fulfilling to be
driving the Ferrari or whatever it is
there's nothing wrong with the Ferrari
but if you're looking to the Ferrari for
happiness and fulfillment and to get you
give you the feeling of
it's not going to work for that long
if you're just driving it because you
enjoy that experience that's a different
matter manifest abundance From the
Inside Out not from the outside is
hoping that you go
find some Interstate through external
things
that is a dilemma of many people who
practice manifesting
which of course manifesting is a
something that
you can use
and it works if it's done rightly
but the Dilemma or the fallacy is
the belief that whatever you manifest
is going to make you happy
it's to seek
the fullness of life through what you
manifest
through things doesn't mind create a
physical problem to distract us from
emotion pain
it is often the case that emotional pain
that is not recognized
when there's not enough awareness
the emotional pain exists but in beneath
your level of awareness and it can come
out as
certain kinds of reactivity in daily
life
so you are taken over by reactions to
certain things that trigger that type of
emotional pain that is in you that
you're completely unaware of
and emotional pain that is in total
unawareness can very easily become
a physical symptom it transferred into
the Physical Realm
any kind of prolonged
negative mental States
which produce
corresponding negative emotions
affect the functioning
of the physical organism
and even research has been done and on
this and been confirmed that
negative States mental emotional states
effect in the long term affect the
physical organism you need the challenge
and you need to challenge yourself
if you want to create something if you
want to
bring about some change in this world
you want to make your life your
so-called life better you are looking to
achieve this or to learn this or to
acquire this that's part of being human
we don't deny that
and if you don't want to achieve
anything let's say you have no ambition
whatsoever I say oh it's all pointless
because you don't want to be you don't
want to challenge yourself
then life will challenge you even more
if you don't if you're challenging
yourself would be even to engage in
physical activity and jogging you're
challenging yourself or you're lifting
weights for your challenging the body on
a physical level the only way you can
make the body stronger the physical body
is by making let's put I'll put it like
this is a strange way of putting it but
it's true
you have to make life difficult for your
body
otherwise it doesn't get stronger
well to lift the weight is I mean if you
ask your body what do you rather have a
good just to relax or lift his weight
no
I just want to relax
I don't want to make but don't make my
life more difficult than it needs to be
so I'll just okay you don't get stronger
without the but when you you make life
difficult for the body then more energy
is demanded and more energy comes
flowing in the energy isn't come until
you demand it there's a request or a
demand for energy because there's a
there's a gap between uh what you want
and what at the moment the body doesn't
have enough energy and suddenly it comes
then you reach a point when an influx of
energy starts then you it's no longer
perceived that the the
you make life difficult for your body
once the Energy starts flowing the body
enjoys this love energy but before the
Energy starts flowing life was difficult
for the body
and so you always you meet always the
the threshold of life gets difficult for
the body and then energy comes in and
then suddenly not even perceived as
difficult anymore and that you may
experience it every day when you start
exercising when I look at you first
thing I would see is your personality or
of course the physical body and the
personality whatever makes up your
personality but if I look more deeply
and not just look but actually sense
your presence I know that beyond your
personality there is an Essence in you
that it is one with the essence in me
and one could describe it as
Consciousness itself the essence of Who
You Are the essence of who I am is
consciousness
when I recognize that Consciousness the
same Consciousness that in me this
Consciousness beyond the condition
itself
recognizes the Consciousness in you that
which is beyond your condition itself
and that recognition
is what Jesus called love
and therefore he said
love thy neighbor as thyself but that as
a separate statement it doesn't work but
when you put it together with Kingdom of
Heaven that then it reads
find the Kingdom of Heaven within you
the dimension of spaciousness
then you will recognize your neighbor
which is anybody that you are with
that you will recognize him or her as
yourself and this recognition that in
essence you are one that you are deeply
deeply connected that you share the one
Consciousness when you recognize them in
the other then you have suddenly an
outflow of benevolence and Good Will and
love
not the ego love but true love towards
the which in the Old Testament in the
New Testament Agape spiritual love for
another human being you can sense their
very beings
so and that's the whole secret of the of
of all spirituality it's in Jesus in the
teaching of Jesus non-attachment to
things
does not mean not appreciating things
but it means not
seeking yourself
or do
regarding things things as an extension
of yourself
or think of things as needing them to
add to yourself
in order to be yourself more fully
that's attachment to things
it's an an ego
dysfunction but in in the way in which
the ego survives
and it's
it's not pleasant because you always
need more and nothing really satisfies
you when if ever you
buy something and seek some kind of
self-satisfaction through it very
quickly
you realize it doesn't work and then you
look for something else
however there is a way of appreciating
things beautiful things or simple things
appreciate is not being attached you can
love even love
a piece of furniture or whatever it is
a little object
or a piece of something you wear too not
saying all this needs to disappear you
can you can like things and appreciate
them love them in a sense of having
appreciate it
without the it without the
seeking in it
and when it the thing leaves you
[Music]
it's you you lose it or it breaks or
it gets stolen or whatever
with all the attachments you'll say oh
it's a Pity but you don't there's no
reaction and no pain you're able to let
go and that's a sign that something you
appreciated and yet when it's not there
anymore
well that's all right too
I always appreciate it since
I
I started in my between the age of 30
and
well up to the age of
30 I don't know 36
my
my main transportation was bicycle
they always had a I always appreciated
my bicycle
uh
and I developed a strange habit
when I parked my bicycle and trained it
to something railing outside whatever
I would take a few steps and look back
on it and just appreciate its its being
is a very strange habit you look back at
it and look back one more time there it
is
and sometimes people ask why are you
looking back at your bicycle are you
proud of it well it wasn't a
particularly special bicycle just to
normal no I just I I appreciate it being
there
and
one day as when then I got in I Got a
Car somebody gave me an old car and then
I lent my bicycle to somebody and one
and suddenly that person came and said
I'm so sorry I lost your bike
I didn't lock it for a few minutes and
now it's gone
and I had already gone through a shift
in Consciousness so it's it's okay it's
gone nothing we can do about it
hopefully somebody else appreciates it
now
then I developed the same habit with my
old car I would look back when it I
parked it I'd look back and just
appreciate it being there
and then do the same now that I have a
much better car and now with my good car
people think I must be proud of this car
or something but it's not that I did the
same with the bicycle
it's a strange habit I'm not
recommending anybody that
he should do that but it's just it's a
way in which I appreciate it it's being
Jesus often talks about
the kingdom of heaven interesting
expression I know there's a line which I
opened the Bible the other day and I saw
the line said Jesus went from Village to
Village and from town to town and said
uh repent for the Kingdom of Heaven is
at hand
and the whole thing is already contained
there repent means it's Miss it's a
mistranslation repentance the original
Greek is metanoia
which means a turnaround a shift a
complete shift
so the repentance what do people think
of it as apologize or something like
that yes beat yourself up I'm such a
miserable sinner that's not that's a
misunderstation of repentance started
when it was translated into Latin into
latiness penitencia which was already
wrong and now we have metanoia as
repentance no a complete reversal a
complete turnaround in other words a
shift in Consciousness repent now what
does he mean by the Kingdom of Heaven no
Christians traditionally believed it's
something that's going to come
that she believe they completely
overlooked when they asked Jesus when
when does the Kingdom of Heaven Come he
said
the Kingdom of Heaven does not come with
observation in another translation it
says the Kingdom of Heaven does not come
with signs to be perceived you cannot
say it's over here or it's over there
for the Kingdom of Heaven is within you
no what is that thing that's within you
where you can never say it's there or
it's there
I I retranslate Kingdom of Heaven into
modern terminology
for Kingdom I would substitute dimension
and Heaven what is heaven when you look
up into heaven you see the vast sky and
the spaciousness of the sky
he used that analogy to point us an
inner reality he is used because
language usually refers to external
things that you can see and touch
so the closest that Jesus could find in
the external world to point to Something
in the inner realm was to look at the
vast spaciousness of the sky which in
itself has no particular form but it's
amazing and he said the kingdom of
heaven then is heaven my translation is
spaciousness
inner spaciousness which is the
uncluttered Mind Consciousness without
conceptual without thought it's inner
alert Stillness
the dimension of spaciousness find the
dimension of that's the primordial
teaching in Jesus finds that within
yourself find the Kingdom of Heaven find
the dimension of inner spaciousness
where you're able to be alert and still
completely conscious but not thinking
and that's the essence of Jesus teaching
in this world dealing with things
creating things achieving things
and being is about
being aware of
the present moment
which after all is all you ever have
whatever you achieve through becoming in
the future eventually
turns into the present moment
so as I speak to you
the meditation if we even want to call
it that
it's perhaps best to forget about the
word
as I speak
be aware of the
start the silence or the Stillness
between the words
being aware means just notice that it's
there
it's very simple
so you notice that
in addition to the words
there's another dimension
that is easily overlooked
and that's the dimension of
Stillness
which we could also call
base
or
spaciousness
so when you notice
that there are two
so to speak
two dimensions
here
dimension of
words
which you
here
and which then become
thoughts
in your head
and
the dimension of
no thing
spaciousness
you just so you just notice that's all
that's required
that there is that Dimension also
present so you notice it
in between words
and even
behind the words
so to speak
now when you notice it
what happens
inside you
what does it mean to notice
the Stillness
be aware of the students
it means
you have become still
inside
it means
you're conscious
but at that moment
at this moment
you're not thinking
but you're allowed
present
completely here
but not thinking
so
that's the realization
of the dimension of depths
within you I have the main focus of your
attention
in your daily life
in the present moment
the rest of your attention so that's the
the main focus here is this
the rest of your attention is
where you want to go to your whatever
task you're engaged in has a certain
purpose
the purpose is you want to finish the
task and it has achieved its purpose and
that's here
and that's in the in your peripheral the
peripheral vision of your Consciousness
that's where you want to get to
and this is what you're doing in order
to get there
and your main attention is not
where you want to get and in the
meantime you're just doing it in order
to get there you can see how that's
already creates an inner stress
I'm here but I want to be there
that's a normal way of living is
the main part of people's attention is
there but in the meantime they are here
where they don't really want to be
rather be there
as shown in famous stickers on bumper
stickers on cars which say something
like I'd rather be fishing
when I visited RAM does the spiritual
teacher who is now passed away he lived
on Maui
on his car I saw a bumper sticker which
said
I'd rather be here now when things go
wrong
that's a moment of becoming more
conscious it's every even the smallest
things
if you don't react out of the
conditioning the mental emotional
conditioning but be the awareness
and then oh
and You observe
if emotions arise you are there and you
can say oh there's the anxiety again and
then you know that there's anxiety
without calling it anything
so this is a huge difference to know
that anxiety is in you anger is in you
right now for example or anxiety
whatever else it may be or some mood the
time League
gets hold of you and then you're
suddenly in a bad mood
don't talk to me don't think
I'm grumpy well if you say I'm grumpy
it's already a little bit step forward
because at least you know that you're
grumpy
oh
if you're totally can't conscious the
grumpiness is you and you don't even
know that you're grumpy
to say it don't talk to me and grumpy
that's already misses a little bit of
awareness there it's great
so there's a huge difference between
saying
I'm angry and
slightly different I feel angry or
there's anger in me I feel that there's
anger in me
I feel angry there's a somewhat a
difference between I am angry because
then you equate identity with emotion
so it's not I am angry that's a beaut
you're falling into a huge trap if you
equate emotion with your identity
or if you equate a thought with your
identity or a story in your mind you
create that with your identity or an
opinion which is thought
the world is full of people who don't
know the difference between their
opinion and their identity their opinion
becomes their identity
and then they have lots of fights with
other people
because they are they are totally
confused about who they are they derive
their identity from a set of opinions
politics for example you derive it
doesn't mean you cannot have opinions
everybody has opinions but where does
your sense of identity come from
does it come from the opinions or do you
realize that you have certain opinions
which may be valid or not you you're on
the human level you have opinions or
viewpoints or perspective mental
positions you have them they are there
yeah
but
do you do this give you your sense of
self or if they do then
you're continuously
arguing with other people making other
people into enemies because
when you contradict somebody who equates
opinion with identity
unconsciously they believe that you are
attack attacking their very self because
there's a confusion about who they are
they don't know who they are
so you you attack the opinion of
somebody who's totally identified with
their opinion and you become their
mortal enemy
they might even try to kill you up in an
extreme form of unconsciousness
affirmations are if they are done
rightly it can be very beautiful
substitutes for prayers
um
I'm Healed and whole and at peace
and after that
let there be a space
and really the power is in that space
in the space you experience that you
already whole
the outward form might tell you
something different
I'm holy causing Miracle says I am Holy
for example that's again you are and so
it's simply an affirmation
of how it this is how it is
or if you're ex healing for somebody
else
you are either with that person
or that person comes into your mind
you're thinking about that person and
that person may be ill
and then the most powerful healing I
find is to be
to hold the image of that person
and then go deeper into yourself
where the wholeness of Life Lies when
nothing is needed nothing is needed to
be added and there you you find the
wholeness also of that person
they already healed at that deepest
level Beyond form they already healed so
you go from form
and then into formlessness happiness or
fulfillment
does not depend on any other humans
acceptance of who you are that would be
a deluded thought if you think you can
only be happy if these people accept and
understand you some people have that
with their parents
they so they say
my dad my father they don't understand
me at all it's terrible terrible I'm
trying to explain what I'm at
of course they under they cannot
understand you it's beyond their
comprehension if you have awakened
spiritually and they haven't
so compassionately accept
that they cannot understand you instead
of trying to explain yourself to them
just be there in a loving way with them
when you meet for Christmas or
Thanksgiving and you hear all the
judgments coming at you from them you
should have why don't you
look where it's taken you look at your
sister she married a millionaire and you
and you are into that weird kind of
meditation stuff that's not getting you
anywhere
whatever judgments come and say okay I
know that this is what you think and
feel and
I I think and feel differently that's
all so you don't not need to justify
you're actually accepting people's
limitations and suddenly realizing
whether or not your father your mother
your sister your brother or anybody else
Close to You accepts you for who you are
is really not you become free of the
need to be accepted but you can
nevertheless have a deeper connection
keep that deeper connection and
connectedness with them I've had this
strange feeling idea in the past few
months
um
that a certain segment of humanity is
losing the ability to think rationally
there's a decrease in without I call it
IQ or whatever it may be
there is a diminishment of rational
faculty
as reflected in many ways on
the mainstream media social media and so
on
uh and another segment of humanity is
actually becoming more aware more where
more conscious is not drawn into
the regressive
phase that some of humanity may be going
through It's Not Unusual for Humanity to
occasionally collectively regress to a
lower State of Consciousness it has
happened
whenever a country or Collective has
been taken over by uh and almost one
could say toxic ideology that has
completely taken possession of millions
of people's minds
look at of course national socialism in
Germany the maoist cultural revolution
was quite crazy what happened in
Cambodia under polar pod
totally crazy ideas
invaded millions of people's minds and
the
reduce their ability to to actually
engage in rational thinking and
it thinks it happened for example in Mao
East China during the cultural
revolution
children reporting on their parents when
they were angry with their parents all
they had to do is go to school and
Report their parents if they had said
something against the
government the pounds would be taken
away and never seen again they they went
around public parks in big cities in
China tearing out flowers out of because
Beauty was regardless Bourgeois you have
to kill your back your pets your your
dogs and cats
totally in these are just a few examples
of totally toxic and irrational thoughts
taking over people's minds so that's to
some extent I've been seeing this
happening
collectively not just in one country in
quite a few Western many Western
countries that I'm aware of and but it
has not affected everybody
some people have managed to remain aware
they have not been one could say
infected by what one could perhaps call
a a mental virus or mental viruses that
reduce people's ability to actually see
reality reality then gets distorted
through the veil of these mental viruses
that have taken over people's minds
um this is
um
uh more serious more serious pandemic
than anything that happens on the
physical level as far as
pandemics are concerned the actual
viruses
actually you might I don't know if
you've read Carl Jung said that the
greatest danger that Humanity faces is
not from any external Force like natural
disasters or
diseases or pandemics that he said the
greatest danger that Humanity faces is
uh
Collective psychosis for someone who's a
little bit hyperactive what's the best
way to get a balance between removing
content which is really good
but then not getting annoyed when
content comes in and you think oh it's
it's spoiling
my piece is there somewhere to get a
balance be more a listener than a
speaker make that your practice for the
time being
I'm not saying don't say a word
but be more like 80 percent a listener
than a speaker and that would for
example you can do by
asking questions when you're in a rather
than stating your view or whatever it is
ask questions that encourages the other
person to speak more
as the other person speaks more it
forces you to listen and then make the
listening into a practice while the
other person is speaking
are you able to let's at any time to
feel your inner body can you feel that
the hands then I seem to lose them quite
quickly okay but but hence you can't
feel the energy in your hands the rest
of the body is more difficult yeah okay
well it's a good start it's a start so I
suggest that once you've asked a
question while you listen
you direct your awareness into the inner
feeling of your hands
and that keeps it there so that it
doesn't your mind doesn't take off
so
you ask a question what
um where you're from how long have you
been with
a card or how did you first discover the
the books
um have you been to other many questions
you can ask and people will be happy to
help you by answering your questions and
they will be happy to help you by not
asking you too many questions
Goods yeah yeah
so and so while you listen
have your attention in the inner energy
field of your hands if if you can
amplify that and have your attention
also in other parts of your body for
example your feet and hand at the same
time that's even better but hence is
fine too so you feel your inner the
aliveness in your hands and from there
you you listen and you know
just giving this will help you
prevent the stream of Mind from taking
you over be aligned with the present
moment rather than carry in your head
this huge amount of mental content
about your past and your future
because the mind is primarily concerned
with past and future
so while you're walking here you're
already thinking about
in a week's time I'll be home again and
then what then I'll have to do that and
have those phone calls to make and then
I'll have to do that and then those
problems will be I shouldn't have come
here because I've got serious so much on
my plate at home why did I come here
I should have dealt with my things there
I should have waited gone to next year's
retreat
as such that's the self-talk in the head
you will May encounter it here too
as you walk from here to there you will
encounter the self-talk in the head
so how do you get out of the self-talk
in the head
one
you need to know that that self-talk in
the head
you don't know itself talking ahead you
become the self-talk in your head you
become the voice in your head you don't
know it you are it
so you have to
the the vital step and I cannot
tell you how to do that
that minimum of awareness needs to be
there where you know
that their self-talk happening in my
head and it's telling you with some kind
of story it could be the briefest of
stories like
I shouldn't have come here or
I don't fit in here all these people up
too spiritual for me or
[Music]
I'm so spiritual these people are not
spiritual at all
it's all little stories in the head
every every even every fragment of
self-talk is a little story in the head
that goes around
and then you look at reality through the
lens of the little story it's not just
one story of course it comes another one
and another it's in some little some
stories are not little they may be big
stories
about yourself
and your life
and what's gone wrong with it or what's
gone right with it thoughts even that's
a story
more pleasant than if it's gone wrong
so you you need to know when the self
self talk happens in the head and
um
The Knowing is not part of the self-talk
The Knowing is just an awareness that
there is self-talk the moment there is
an awareness that there is self-talk the
possibility of freedom from the
self-talk opens up I will probably be
talking
for almost of the time
but there may be
quite a few gaps
of Stillness in between the words
as they are now
and these gaps are very important
I would even say more important than the
words if you become conscious of these
gaps of Stillness
in between words
you notice the gaps
instead of just impatiently
being in your conceptual mind and saying
why is he talking so slowly
why hasn't he said anything even
significant yet
if you are able to notice the gaps give
them attention
that is the arising of
that State of Consciousness that we call
a presence
it is a state of
alertness
relaxed alertness
clarity
a state in which the conceptual mind
has come to arrest
and something else arises
thinking is most people's normal state
of when they are awake in conventional
terms
and
when you become aware of these gaps
thinking subsides
and presence or we call it awareness
arises
thinking subsides
presence arises of course thinking will
come back but it has
briefly momentarily subsided something
else has emerged
and
that is
what we call presence
it is a state of
one could say pure awareness or pure
consciousness
so
foreign
people
hope to achieve and embed it when they
actually do formal meditations
meditation is a good tool
but it's not enough
it's not even for everybody
the most important thing is to bring
that state of clear alert presence
into everyday life there was a long time
when I had resentment towards my father
because my father was pretty unconscious
except very late in life I had a very
strong ego and living with him as a
child was living with an unexploded bomb
that could go off at any moment without
these intense rages would suddenly come
several times a week so I lived in a
constant state of kind of
background anxiety but is when is this
mom going to explode again next and then
for a long time it was in my twenties I
had a resentment towards him until I
went to this shift in Consciousness and
I suddenly realized
he he did what he had to do but there
wasn't enough awareness in him to act
any different so he was at the mercy of
his own conditioning
and once you see that you no longer make
it into an identity for him and so you
free him and really perhaps this is the
meaning of forgiveness you can forgive
yourself by not making unconscious
behavior in your past into an identity
for yourself or for somebody else you
may be surprised to know that there are
millions billions of people on the
planet who have that same thought
pattern there is something wrong with me
it's part of the human ego
but so you bring in the awareness
and that will change
everything
that's the only true key
if you fail next time you're the anger
arises
what happens you will become aware
immediately after the anger has subsided
and then with oh there it was and I
wasn't present
and then the the
moment will come when you are there in
the first if you can catch the anger the
first moment it comes
or if you might even see that it could
be the result of a thought
that creates the anger and if you can be
there in the first moment because before
it becomes the fully blown
anger then you can stay there and it
might not even become fully blown anger
if you catch it the first moment you can
feel the first stirrings of anger you
may only have three seconds
it may come very quickly and goes like
an explosive energy
you may only have two three four five
seconds
to to bring the stay there with your
awareness and feel it oh that it's
coming there it is that's the pain body
the angry pain body coming and if you
catch it in the early stage don't
suppress it by catch it I mean
feel it be there as a witness then
you can stay even as it grows the
witness grows with it it may not even
grow they will have to see whether it
still grows into full-blown anger or not
that doesn't matter
and so you be thankful for your anger
because the anger can become a very
important spiritual practice for you
because through it awareness can grow
so it's it's a sometimes strange for
people to see you can be thankful for
things that you think are
the most difficult obstacles in your
life
but they become
they can become your greatest
opportunity for for Spiritual Awakening
use it
as part of your practice life without
love is no life at all
now what does that mean life Without
Love
can only be there
when you're connected to the source of
life
who you are Beyond form
it's illness spaciousness and then from
there
you perceive you relate
you operate you do what you do
and
there's a sense of Oneness no longer a
sense of Separation you're one with the
present moment
you're one with whoever you meet because
the separation comes through mental
Concepts
and that sense of Oneness is love
it's a recognition that
you share
with every life form you share
the same consciousness
so it's always a self-recognition you
see you sense rather than see yourself
in the other
that is love there's an innate human
feeling you see something and it has a
lot of attention and it's shiny and it's
whatever and that everyone wants to get
in but basically you're saying if you
would take that breath if you would just
say I don't want in on this
that eventually you can actually you can
almost pull other people out of it too
by your own behavior yes because this
isn't just about you yes also not to
feed uh
other if other people post negative
things about you in many many cases
non-reaction is the best thing instead
of feeding it that's a lesson I need to
learn I will try to take that one with
me that applies both offline and online
in your personal life too often it's
just well I believe Jesus was talking
about non-reaction where these talked
about turning the other cheek I don't
think it's to be taken literally
but it means when somebody somebody
attacks you not not physically it's an
analogy he uses a it's a parable uh turn
the other thing is it means to just be
free of reaction
and that uh that uh
very quickly deflates even the the other
person's ego it doesn't the ego needs
the reaction it needs the reactivity
so that's a powerful thing but how do
you avoid then just becoming a pushover
within that well in some situations
something needs to be said but even then
that can come from you could say let's
especially if you're with somebody
that kind of behavior is unacceptable
you can say that
um in a conscious way rather than you
know destructive and aggressive way you
can but can actually be very firm and
conscious
or when you say no to somebody
it doesn't have to be
aggressive it's just really a clear is I
call it a high quality no
somebody says can you lend me again I've
the two thousand dollars I need I know I
still owe you 20 000 but I need some
more and then and then not to make the
other engine enemy just no I'm sorry I
can't do it anymore it's a high quality
no that's uh your present while you say
it and then you can set boundaries if
necessary
so in some cases
something needs to be said I need to do
something but in many other cases
complete non-reactivity can be very very
powerful the normal thing to happen is
that
this the connectedness with your essence
identity is lost very easily in human
relationships
because the mind is so active
and we live in a civilization that
provides
continuously continuous and incessant
stimulus stimuli is the plural
continuous incessant stimuli for the
mind even more than even 30 years ago
30 years ago it was just radio and
television and you would people would
sit there for hours
but nowadays you have countless sources
of stimulus for them for the mind and it
draws you into continuously
thinking about
what's your next Facebook post what's it
going to be and you look at the ones
that are coming in all these people are
doing these fantastic things
and me I'm just sitting here and then
you have to pretend that you are also
doing fantastic things
and usually it involves taking a nice
selfie
and the new project yourself image which
has existed for a long long time before
in humans they have a they haven't this
is part of ego is to have this image of
who I am
and but in in these Facebook now we have
the opportunity to project that image
into the world
and it'll reach hundreds or thousands of
people
all at once
and then you you construct your life you
there are many people alive these days
without knowing it they partly live for
their Facebook image and they're just
looking for the next thing that they can
project out into the world it's
Narcissus
well you might remember the myth of
Narcissus the Greek ancient Greek means
there was this young man who had never
seen himself before because they didn't
have mirrors at the time but one day he
happened to look into a little pool of
water
and he saw himself and he realized that
he was extremely beautiful he said oh
that's me
and it's The Story Goes he fell in love
with himself
not in a good way
[Music]
not by becoming one with who he is but
but the separation happens this myth
shows the the beginning stage of the
egoic sense of self expressed as a story
the image that is of himself in the pool
is the mental image of the ego said and
stories are part of that image that's me
I'm me and my story so you have the
image of me
and then oh so this guy that says us
he experienced that separation
uh
and then I think something bad happened
to him but I don't remember a word
so and then you have other Divine things
that continuously stimulate the minds
that almost designed for you not
to not to to to become still it's like
the civilization
it has made a great effort to come up
with as many things as possible to
prevent people from becoming still and
spacious and taking a moment of
looking at the sky and feeling the inner
spaciousness arise and becoming aware of
the
the leaves of the tree or the branches
and the wind blowing and it
the noise of water
the simple thing becoming still
a large sensing
that Stillness within almost everybody
uh
has in one way or another
being a victim of other people but in
some cases much much more so than in
others
some element of having been victim is
probably present in everybody's life
in other words you're surrounded by
unconscious humans and then unconscious
humans will inflict suffering on
themselves and others
that's just how it is when you're alive
in this on this planet
uh childhood particularly is a place
where many many children experience
um
abuse
either minor forms of abuse emotional
abuse or they live in a very toxic
family environment and then of course
the other children who are experience
for much more serious forms of abuse and
really uh
suffer and have these care and carry
with them
or the the memory both mental and
emotional memory of the what happened to
them in some cases the memory is
repressed because the child the emotions
may be repressed the child could not
deal with them and they had to repress
them and then later
the possibility of remembering arises
and then you remember what happened to
you
and how do you do the question what do
you do
with what happened to you what was done
to you
how do you deal with what was done to
you by other humans whether it happened
in childhood
or whether it happened later in life
whether it was a relatively minor thing
or whether it was a very serious form of
abuse
how do you how do you deal with that
now the the ego the human ego
is always looking for
something to add to its sense of
identity it's looking for a stronger
sense of identity because it always
feels I'm not enough
so it's it's going it's trying to add
something that it can identify with so
adds to its sense of self
and it very often happens that the
memory of of having been abused
is used by the ego
that is added
to the ego's sense of self so that means
you not only remember what happened to
you
the memory of what happened to you which
is
a bundle of thoughts and emotions that
go with it
the memory of what happened to you is
more than just a memory
there is
self-identification with the memory in
other words it's not not perceived it's
just something that happened to you but
it becomes part of who you perceive to
be so I am a victim of that it's not
that this was done to me but I am a
victim of so it's the transition from
memory to self
that is the victim identity the ego does
that
because the victim identity is a very
powerful form of identity a very
powerful form of ego
and particularly in cases where the the
ego is always is
does not find sufficient
things that it can identify with in this
world because the most common form of
identification for example is with
the way you look
uh you look
better than others so you can identify
with that
if you look worse than others of course
that we could become part of your victim
identity because you've been treated
unfairly by life and life has made you
look worse than others that could become
part of victim identity although it's
not actually abuse but it could all also
be incorporated into victim identity
there are millions of people in this
world who believe in God
and have no access have not found within
themselves access to the spiritual
dimension
so
we are here
in the case of some of you who are
perhaps new to this so to speak
we are here for some of you to get
perhaps a glimpse of it as you sit here
and watch and listen
and I will endeavor to put you in touch
with that
depth
Within You Without which
your life is frustrating
and without which everything you
undertake every Endeavor and every
activity
ultimately becomes frustrating
and for others
we are here just to
to deepen it to provide a reminder on a
conceptual level
but to deepen the dimension that they
already have access to Within
so that it can be sustained in everyday
life
one thing is
accessing the spiritual dimension in a
meditation setting like Here and Now
that's already a good thing if you are
able to do that when you sit still
become still inside
another thing is to
carry that with you so to speak so that
it is there when you lead your life
when you do things
talk to people interact
even when you think
to have that in the background
so we have the two steps one could
almost say first is you you
realize that within when you're not
being disturbed like now hopefully
you're not being disturbed externally
although you may be disturbed as you sit
here by your mind that's quite possible
who says what is he talking about
if the mind doesn't understand it the
conceptual mind alone is not sufficient
to make this
a satisfying experience for you so for
this to be a satisfying experience you
need to
have at least a glimpse of what it is
that
I am pointing to
and a glimpse also of
that which underlies the words
and that's ultimately not in me but
ultimately you can only Glimpse that in
you
there's a Stillness behind the words
as I speak Within Myself
and it can be a Stillness in you
as you listen to the words
and that would already be
a glimpse of the spiritual Dimension so
part of this is of course to be
give more attention to the present
moment
because the more you think the more
future you generate
[Music]
and the more tension you give to the
present moment
a little less thinking because to be
really present you don't think about it
you just are with it give it attention
foreign
the little things of life to be more
attentive
to all the little things that make up
every hour every day
every minute every hour
and
give them more attention
[Music]
walking steps one step at a time
objects that you're handling your all
the time you're handling objects in your
life they always
touching something putting something
here there
is everything that you handle Justin
means to an end or are you able to just
appreciate the simple presence or even
of a so-called inanimate object
contemplation also of
all the lovely things that make up your
environment
part of your environment
for example if I were sitting here alone
let's say I'm waiting for everybody to
arrive
I might be sitting in looking across at
the flower
sense of Stillness and then there's a
glass table here
and then there's a glass of water here
and there's a clock and a bell and
tissues
and they all reflect the light in
different ways
there's a little bit of a rainbow effect
in the glass of water here
and then the lines are reflected on the
the belts almost like a mirror
and there's the clock ticking away
it's a beautiful scenes sometimes you go
to an art gallery well not so much but
Modern Art but it very favorite favorite
thing would be still live artists and it
took a while in art before they
discovered these the artists in the
history of art before they discovered
the seemingly insignificant things and
started to give attention to those
before that happened they were very much
interested in the huge things
the Saints or the Kings or the huge
battle scenes or the the big they had to
they painted those things or the
important people uh or some dramatic
thing the volcanic eruption or whatever
a fire
and then at some point they started to
discover
the beauty and the incredible
[Music]
sense of
the quality that is in the little things
perhaps after these more of these
artists depicted relatively in seemingly
insignificant things perhaps it
motivated some people to give more
attention
to that
but even now it's still
people very much Overlook that and you
overlook then in a large part of your
life you don't give it attention
when I say give attention
there's an element of appreciation of
everything of the little things and you
begin to realize that your entire life
consists mainly
of little things if you find the strange
phenomenon that you are always right and
others are always wrong it's an
important realization how is it possible
I must be superhuman
and
in the eyes of the ego of course
that's kind of the case
because the ego
which is that which is
perhaps the major
obstacle
towards the realization
of their deeper dimension
in the the ego
strives
incessantly
for
some kind of
superiority
and so this is what you are condemned to
when you have not yet
awakened even
just at least to some extent
to the deeper essence of Who You Are
the awareness
the presence
the Stillness
then you are in the
prison
of your own personality
and it's not a pleasant place to be
I sometimes watch people
into their soul
burdened with their personalities so in
the grip
of that thing what is personality
it's the sum total
of their mental emotional conditioning
from the past
mental emotional conditioning mental
conditioning means certain
thought forms mind structures that
become repetitive
certain narratives
concerning
your life my life says the ego certain
narrative concerning
my other people in my life
what I did what they did to me my
victories my defeats what many things
form the the egoic condition itself and
one important aspect of the egoic
condition itself is it
it talks about
my life all the time in the head and out
allowed
[Music]
in my life
is what concerns me obviously it's my
life and what is my life
it's a story in my head but they don't
know that
they think it's the reality but it's a
story in my head it's a narrative it's
the predominant narrative
it in my mind
and it's the narrative through which
I interpret
everything that comes like come into
contact with it becomes a screen
through which I interpret other people
situations places events
I don't know that because I am so
identified
was that mental emotion conditioning
that it has become me
it has become
me and my life
it's I don't know anything else
that's the Fate
still
of the
majority
of humans
on the planet
all the the minority that is Awakening
is growing
it is still
a minority
most humans are still totally in the
grip
of their egoic self and probably
most of you
are moving still
in and out
of your echoic self take your attention
more deeply into
being or into the tension itself
purely practical don't turn on the TV in
your room
please
I have not installed hidden cameras to
take on you
second
limit your interaction the interaction
with your devices
if you cannot eliminate interaction with
your devices completely and I understand
that you may not survive if you do
at least put aside just
maybe once a day 15 minutes
when you check your
whatever it is that comes through
whatever
text
email
um
Facebook
Snapchat
tender
it's all very important but
there's something more important and
that's why you're here
if you
so now let's see I suggest to you that
you
make an agreement with yourself
that not to
go there
unless any more than is absolutely
necessary how do I strike a healthy
balance between simply accepting life as
it unfolds and actively working towards
and striving towards goals destinations
aspirations well accepting life as it
unfolds of course is the foundation for
conscious and sane living accepting
whatever
unfolds in the present moment there is
nothing else
that's the foundation doesn't mean you
cannot
have
goals
you cannot have aspirations wanting to
achieve this do this do that it's
perfectly compatible with accepting what
is arriving in this moment
one difference between the unconscious
state which denies this moment and wants
to make it into a means to an end all
the time
difference then is
what is the motivation for your doing
If you deny this moment
can never embrace it honor it appreciate
it
then the motivation for your action is
basically dissatisfaction with what is
and the action is looked towards as a
possible way of overcoming the
discontent and the dissatisfaction that
you feel with the present moment
and that's a very normal pattern and
that's in for many many people that what
is what motivates them they don't feel
good enough they don't feel
with some they feel there's something
fundamental missing in their lives they
don't feel recognized they don't feel
loved
whatever and so they try to find
something achieve something that will
bring them that which they feel is
missing
they don't realize that
that is not going to work
you need to start with
the foundation for your life which is
this moment
and go deeply into that
and become
okay with it friendly with it realize
it's the only thing there ever is just
this moment nothing ever exists that's
not this moment
so you might as well
become friendly with it and appreciate
it
and look around and see how actually
it's okay this moment is actually okay
and if it's not okay that you can still
say well that's what it is right now
something goes wrong that's what is
and then things will come in that you
want to do you suddenly an idea comes or
you need to do something to make a
living
and then out of that state of becoming
one with the isness of the present
moment
something Rises and wants it wants to
take form in the world that perhaps you
want to create and then you created out
of the joy of doing instead of out of a
feeling of lack that you need something
to make you complete or happy
so the motivation change is from
neediness and discontent
to
joyful doing
it's not stressed anymore
when stress is a sign that you've lost
the present moment
the next moment has become more
important than life itself you won't
really enjoy the fruit of your labors
if habitually you cannot be present in
the moment
no matter what you achieve the enjoyment
will be short-lived because of the
habitual pattern
of dissatisfaction in the background
it's always there some obscure sense of
lack and often it comes into the
foreground There's real unhappiness
frustration
and then if you realize that there's
always this waiting for the next thing
which is a thought when you're waiting
for the next thing you're trapped in
thought because that's where future
happens
now
the realization that this is happening
to you is very important the first step
is the beginning of something else
arising
and in all of you that has already
Arisen or that occasionally it still
gets obscured perhaps probably I assume
something else has arisen that's not
thought that is beyond thought the
ability to recognize thought
the ability to recognize certain
patterns that habitually arise in your
mind your mental emotional field
the ability to witness that which arises
in your mental emotional field
that's an enormous
believing consciousness
another dimension one could say has
arisen
we could call it presence we could call
it awareness
it's not thought
but its intelligence
so intelligence is not confined to
thought
there is a dimension in you
that is far
greater far more intelligence than any
intelligent thought
it's the place from where all
intelligence arises a place of where all
creativity arises
[Music]
so there's the ability to suddenly be
aware of your inner states to be aware
of what's what your mind is saying that
the narrative the habitual narrative
that you're telling yourself you're
having a monologue or many people have a
dialogue with themselves where they
split themselves in two and then this
one argues with the other why aren't you
good enough why did you do this why do
you never get anything right you
shouldn't have he shouldn't have said
that yes but on the other so you can
have a dialogue in your narrative or you
can have a monologue it says I am such a
miserable creature because a lot of the
time the narratives the unconscious
thought processes tend to be more
negative than positive for many many
people
so to be aware that this is happening
that's an enormous gain in continence
it's the beginning of Awakening oh
spiritually speaking
something arises that is not part of the
conditioned mind patterns
so there's the ability to observe your
inner states and that's a wonderful
little pointer to ask yourself
[Music]
frequently
wants my inner State at this moment
and then look at it direct your
attention to it the narratives what have
I been telling myself
[Music]
and the emotion that accompanies the
narrative
what am I feeling what's the emotion
so in addition to it being a story in
your head
and an emotion
there's a knowing behind it
there's a space behind it
sometimes I call it Inner Space there's
an inner space
from where you can be aware of what's
Happening
on the level of the person the
personality
because that Inner Space the awareness
is not part of the personality it's but
it's the being
the knowing that it's inherent in the
being you can look at the world wars you
can look at all the the terrorism and
all the other mad Wars that are being
fought
as just
it's just a question of degrees of
unconsciousness not different
so when you go into that state of
unconsciousness you it takes you over
you lose it
basically then that is the same energy
field
that has created
what we see as the Mad Madness of human
history
and what we see of The Madness of the
so-called world news
same energy so don't complain about
all these violent people who are doing
all these Dreadful things all that it is
is human or unconsciousness in a more
pronounced form than yours
or your partners
and so
that helps a little bit to find perhaps
it's almost some compassion
towards
all these crazy people
that are doing such crazy things and
creating such terrible suffering now if
you become compassionate towards them
don't worry
it doesn't mean that they will not
experience
the consequences of their
unconsciousness that still happens you
just by being compassionate to another
human being you don't necessarily remove
the karmic consequences of their action
but
you yourself
become free from the from being drawn
into the karmic cycle
so the the act of forgiveness
does not mean
that this person is not going to suffer
the consequences because life makes sure
in whatever form that they do suffer the
consequences of the suffering that they
inflict on other human beings it's a
karmic law
but if you don't want to be part of that
anymore if you want to step out of the
karmic law the the first step out of the
and the most important step out of the
karmic law is forgiveness
[Music]
then you do not feed it you don't become
part of it that's why traditionally in
spiritual teachings of various
traditions
forgiveness is always emphasized it must
be real though it's there are many forms
of superficial forgiveness when Justin
minus okay I forgive you it's not deep
it's not real yet
the mind is trying to forgive but you
you can only forgive
if you realize that whatever actions
have been perpetrated are the effects of
human unconsciousness
in other words what Jesus said on the
cross or is reported to have said
forgive them for they know not what they
do
very profound statement it is a profound
statement that can be applied
to any Act of
violence perpetrated against other
humans or life forms forgive them for
they know not what they do
not knowing what they do of course means
they are unconscious
the word unconscious probably in that
sense wasn't used at the time
so he said they don't know what they do
common law still operates
but without you
and you can notice coming law
[Music]
when when you see a movie some movies
like to manipulate your emotions
and so there are particular types of
movies where they first they built up
the tension by showing you some very
evil persons
and this evil person is killing all
these people or hurting all these people
and then you're being manipulated
to feel that incredible pull that this
person should suffer for what he or she
has done that's the manipulation the
audience loves that they love watching
things like that
so then the emotion builds up and
finally there even some movies like The
the movies that uh about um
Vigilantes who take justice in their own
hands because the justice system doesn't
deal with the criminals anymore so
finally you have this guy who goes out
and kills all the bad guys and the your
emotions have been manipulated so much
that the audience that yes yes he must
die not realize no what you what you are
free what what you are feeling this
incredible it might also happen if you
read about some Dreadful crime that
somebody has committed and then if you
read it on the internet the you can read
in some on some news websites you can
read the comment section
and in the comment section on every
other comment says we should have the
death penalty who needs to say electric
chair he needs to be
done to what he did he they should do to
him and all these and this is an
enormous pressure that people feel
inside and this is connected to karmic
law because there's a compensatory
factor in karmic law and you can feel
that as the pressure inside you but it
keeps you trapped in karma
so in that sense watching these movies
is not helpful
because it keeps you trapped in that
that wheel of the of karma so they don't
teach forgiveness there so
this is we are talking it's about
something very important and that is
dealing with human unconsciousness and
what looks like evil do they saw there
are many things that uh
quite Dreadful so how do we how does
that affect our state of consciousness
and what role does our state of
consciousness play in this whole
scenario it does have a role to play
so it's
for us
important that we are no longer part of
action and reaction because the
definition of karma is action Karma
means action and reaction and it goes on
and on and as you can see in certain
societies and so on the karmic thing
goes on what goes back centuries and
centuries the same grievance
transmitted from one generation to the
next and the next and the next and they
are all asleep
this is why spiritual teaching say you
are asleep they are all so unconscious
they get taken over by the collective
mental emotional pattern and the mental
story they just inherited from their
parents and then they pass it on to
their children and then they and each
generation suffers they suffer they call
my suffer being created for each each
other
and at some point
the suffering becomes almost unbearable
for certain people within that society
and that's the beginning of
a shift when it gets too much so
suffering drives humans
to appoint
of Awakening it's a strange Paradox here
is
the suffering is created by the
unconsciousness in humans
but in some strange way
eventually
it wakes you up it awakens you
that's the redeeming feature behind the
suffering that humans create for each
other
eventually it leads to a spiritual
awakening
so
it always a good thing to realize it all
comes down to your state of
consciousness
and how you relate to the people around
you and that spreads that is what
creates the world
and even how you react to when you
listen to the world news
it has a certain influence because all
[Music]
all human minds are connected at a
deeper level
so the way in which you react to what
you hear on the world news contributes
either to the unconsciousness if you get
only on your computer or the iPad and
you type in
this guy does not deserve to live
[Music]
should be
die slowly
then you become part of the same Karma
if you've ever done that please forgive
yourself
foreign
and if you enjoy reading those comments
also forgive yourself the greatest
obstacle is probably
when meditation comes out of a sense of
lack or neediness so you feel you you
are deprived of something be it money or
relationship or a living situation and
you feel there's a great lack in your
life and you desperately want this to
change
and so you perhaps
use manifestation in a way that is not
likely to work when for example you
use affirmations such as
I want a better job I want a job isn't
as a good income and a life situation in
a nice place and I want this and I want
that
by making these statements
uh you're actually by implication saying
that you don't have it
so yeah also by saying that you are
there's a reverse side to your statement
I want and on the reverse side of the
statement I want there is the statement
I don't have and I need
and similar things please give me if you
you pray to
maybe God maybe you pray to Jesus maybe
you pray to Buddha they do that in
Buddhist countries maybe you pray to a
saint or whatever it is or you pray to
the universe and say please the universe
please give me this please give me that
that also doesn't work very well if it
works
it could be accidentally who knows but
usually that greatly diminishes your
power of manifestation because it is the
manifestation practice arises out of a
state of lack or neediness so there's no
powerful manifestation there
The Secret of manifestation is expressed
in one simple statement by Jesus and
that encapsulates
all the books
that have been written on manifestation
and will ever be written on
manifestation is just one simple
sentence it says when you pray for
something believe that you
that it has been given or that you
already have it and then you will
receive it
so the important thing is he doesn't say
believe that you will receive it
it says believe that you have received
it
so there the secret is hiding in that
statement believe that you have received
it my North Star is the monk the story
you shared about the monk who lived
saying is that so
for everything that came I am trying
my best to get there in my journey to
accepting the easiness of things and
accepting the moment what I'm struggling
with is
when am I being a doormat how do I
determine it's clear in the example you
just shared being homeless in the gray
areas of life how do I determine when I
need to take action the important thing
is
non-resistance is not so much to do what
externally what you do but it's a it's
an inner state of consciousness of
non-resistance acceptance of what is of
the present moment in this this moment
um
it doesn't if it's misunderstood then it
could lead as you say it could lead you
to become a doormat because then you
would go along with with what everybody
say anybody says to you uh
and you would can you do this can you do
this for me yeah okay I can do it
and then you could be used by people
um
but a state of non of non-resistance
sometimes
um
may require you to say no
to uh let's say somebody request
something but you feel you don't want to
do it or you cannot do it
uh for some reason
and you say no
I I don't I think I wrote about this I I
had this expression
a high quality no
as opposed to a low quality no a low
quality noise you make the other person
into
a kind of enemies and
why you always ask me this like what do
you remember you should argue in
yourself you accuse the other bird
you're just trying to use me I can see
it you've used me before and now you're
doing it again now you're asking me for
money again I've already lent you five
times here have you given it back to me
no you haven't
so no I'm not going to do it just don't
leave me alone
that's one no
and then there's another no which is
non-reactive it's not all right does not
arise from reactivity but is a response
to the situation that says uh no I don't
want to let's say whatever the request
is or the demand no I I can't do it
anymore I don't want to do it anymore no
I'm not going to give you money again
because I've already given you five
times so uh this um I won't give you
again uh that's just how it is I know I
can't uh no I no I cannot
[Music]
foreign
no
without creating an enemy without
treating or a situation without making a
situation into an enemy
so it's a conscious no and you're still
in an inner state of non-resistance
the state of resistance strengthens the
ego and this is a way of not operating
through not operating through ego I
wonder could to connect that to what I'm
doing with this month
um I I suppose someone like you kind of
kind of digs something like this the
idea that someone could put down the
devices and I wonder what what do you
think just in general about a world that
is so obsessively connected to other
people's thoughts all day long yes
that's good so um the over this
excessive identification with thinking
and overthinking excessive thinking have
been there for a long time long before
we came up with these devices
but these devices
amplify the human tendency to to engage
or indulge in excessive thinking and
problem making thinking rather than
constructive thinking focused thinking
uh so the what you are doing
is very very helpful because you are
basically
[Music]
having a period of what we could call it
decluttering your mind you declutter
your mind and this is necessary because
our mind most people's minds have never
been again as cluttered as they are now
Gladden means there's a continuous input
of
stuff that comes in through the devices
the messages come in Facebook posts
tweets and continuously the devices
demand your attention and say this is
important and a lot of it is not
important but as we all know
there's an addictive quality to it it
draws your attention to it and then
every time it draws your attention you
add to the Clutter of your mind a lot of
not is not constructive
a lot of it is just random people often
see people they get out their phones
and they do this random scrolling I can
see it's random there's nothing specific
but they think they have to do it
because everybody else is doing it
around them wherever you are these days
people are engaging with this and
they're continuously taking in
thoughts from others and as we said
before
some of these thoughts may be toxic and
they may easily become lost in your mind
so to declutter is extremely important
and you can see if you even just not
using a device for a day for many people
is very very hard
and some think they can do it but they
can't so they are truly addicted
um
no when you when you when you declutter
your mind first of all you put down your
phone you don't use it not everybody can
do it for whole months like you of
course but I recommend to everybody to
have certain periods of time when they
do not engage so for example in your
bedroom might be a good place to start
for not engaging with any device uh
certain periods of time when you go out
into nature
be there rather than carry that thing
and every time it makes a noise you
still look up and you still even while
you're surrounded by Beauty and your
liveness you're still engaging with this
and the moment you watch the screen
whether it's television or whatever
screen you might have noticed that
the your own your so-called own thought
processes come to a stop so to some
extent you're free of the self this is
why people sometimes find watching
television relaxing say okay I just need
to relax now let's turn it on
by this they mean while they watch the
television screen they are not burdened
by their
self-induced thought processes what they
do however they replace
the their own Thoughts with the for
Collective thoughts so they just the
United States you're not in a state of
thoughtless awareness when you watch
television or you watch something on the
screen you absorb
the thoughts from there into your mind
and you you link in so it for people
often in a state of semi or hypnosis
when they was and it kind of paralyzes
you it can also happen with the screen
with television already started of
course
um I don't know when whenever 60 years
ago whenever television started and you
go
and so your mind is just absorbing
whatever is playing it's the TV Minds
which is receiving stuff from where it
comes from it's going into your mind and
you become a
no longer thinking your own thoughts
occasionally your mind you say oh this
guy is so stupid and then you're
watching again
and then another thought why am I
watching this rubbish
half an hour later
this is so awful
but you can't you can't you can't turn
it off
here's the here's the remote
let's let's just try one more Channel
there might be something out there
oh no that's stupid try one more
this is this is how an addict behaves
and the device is even more addictive
you go because you have to carry them
with you
and
you have to admit you may have to admit
that
you there's an addiction in you that not
everybody here but quite a few it would
be almost normal to feel this draw
towards it and you use it even when you
don't need to use it that's the amazing
thing
when you're standing at the elevator
waiting so another person is standing
next to you and he or she is pulling out
the phone
and then you pull out yours if you don't
know why
anywhere you are in a you are waiting
you're ordering a tea or coffee
somewhere and you're standing in line
and if you look around there's almost
nobody and probably nobody who is not
looking at this little thing
this is scary
zombie-like the feeling
first of all needs to be acknowledged
and accepted
you can't start with letting go so you
have to start with acknowledging it
and accepting that it's there because
it's part of what is the easness of the
present moment whether it's an external
thing or an inner thing it is it is what
is
and to deny or to argue with what is
creates suffering
so
you acknowledge you accept that it's
there
then
how much time you need
to be with it
depends varies from person to person and
what what kind of feeling it is and so
on
and then the question arises what is the
link between that feeling and your
thought processes
the
the person needs to find out
whether the thought process is
keep that feeling alive continuously
whether they renew by playing out for
example a past scenario in their minds
by Reviving memories from the past
by dwelling on certain narratives that
are painful
repeating them in their minds that gives
Renewed Energy to the feeling
so the first the most important thing is
to be aware of both levels
what's the level of my thinking how does
that contribute to the perpetuation of
what I feel
and so you also then acknowledge that oh
this these are the habitual thought
patterns that go through my mind in
relation to the feelings
and then the you would begin to realize
that
the Letting Go the most important step
in letting go of feelings is to cut the
link between
your thinking and what you're feeling
how do you do that
you do it by
by being aware of your thinking and
realizing
that that thinking is pain
it feeds the old feeling and the
narrative whatever it is is a painful
narrative
and you realize that you've been keeping
it alive for some years
and you when you there's some enough
awareness you realized that it has no
purpose
except to make you unhappy and to
perpetuate that feeling the Dao
or consciousness
in its pure form
is pure no form
before it becomes something before it
becomes
the thought
or words
so right now
you're aware of
sense perceptions because you can still
see me
you're aware of the words
but more importantly
you are aware
that you are aware you know yourself
as
this aware presence
space
without that space that aware space
you would there would be no sense
perception
it is the light
of consciousness
in which
or the object of Consciousness are
perceived
most people are not aware of themselves
as consciousness
they're only aware of the object that
arise in consciousness
and their sense of identity also
their sense of who they are
ultimately
is an object
that arises in their consciousness
that's me
this is my story me and my story my
identity
I am this and that and that and all
those things together that's me
but they're all thought forms or
emotional forms that arise in
Consciousness they are an object in
Consciousness and this updating
Consciousness for most people
is the founder the foundation of their
sense of identity
but that unfortunately is a
an enormous
limitation
and ultimately a misperception
of who they actually are
most people's sense of identity
therefore is based on a misperception
because who you truly are is not an
object in consciousness
that's ephemeral it it is here for a
while then it evaporates
who you truly are
is the space of Consciousness itself
and so you become aware of an underlying
presence just to use a word
and an awakefulness
a certain alertness
a Stillness
but not a Stillness that is asleep
an alert Stillness
that's the realization
of consciousness
of yourself
as Consciousness let's just uh
take a moment
and become aware
[Music]
of the present moment
vitally important
in any endeavor
that you undertake
no matter what it is
not to lose
your connectedness
with the present moment
[Music]
so before you start a new Enterprise a
new activity
always go to take a moment for
awareness basically that's what it is
sometimes people ask
well
what is the present moment how how do
you be
where is it what does it even mean to
become aware of the present moment
and the first thing of course is that
you become aware of whatever surrounds
you
that's the entry point into the present
moment
the very easy entry point into a present
moment awareness
some people may call it mindfulness
is to become more aware of whatever
surrounds you here and now
sense perceptions just be with what it
is
give it attention some attention
the room you're sitting in
maybe there's a window you can look out
of the window
you can see trees behind me I can't see
them I know they're there
this is you enter the Present Moment by
becoming more aware of science
perceptions auditory Visual and perhaps
others
and of course what that does you might
notice
is there is less
mental noise
the voice in the head that speaks and
speaks
that talks to you or that you have a
dialogue with a monologue that comments
and interprets and
takes positions mental positions it
identifies with
likes dislikes there's no
never stops talking
lets the mind the
the voice in the head that most people
are completely identified with and that
means they are not present so the first
step is
take some attention away from that
by simply becoming way of sense
perceptions
[Music]
and if you can look at something natural
that's even better because a natural
thing a tree a flower a plant a sky
a natural thing
lends itself
to
the presence moment awareness more than
a man-made a human-made thing so
anything natural that you can look at
for moment focus on
and
give it attention acknowledge it
you don't need to think about it so it's
just come away of the present moment
through a sensory perception and already
if you can do that if perhaps a few
minutes before you were very much
immersed in the
problem-making mind
it wasn't actually solving any problem
because this continuous mind activity
actually creates more problems than it
solves
if it's not focused it's unconscious
so already certainly there's a certain
amount of peace that descends upon this
the world the old world
it becomes a bit more peaceful
you become aware of the aliveness of
things to practice self-observation
is
implies
that there is enough presence or
awareness in you from where you can
self-observe
and in almost all of you there is maybe
not all the time
but there is there is enough to have
brought you here and that it was quite a
bit
so is there enough presence in you so
that you can self-observe your own
motivations your own thought structures
what are the habitual thoughts that I
think
so that you are not drawn continuously
into every thought that comes and follow
it where it wants to take you one little
thought comes in about your life or and
then another thought and you follow it
oh
oh no
and then before you know it you
more thoughts coming than other
conflicting thoughts and no no that's
not how it is yes it is no
I can't take anymore and you believe in
that thought too that you can't take
anymore
[Music]
so the ability to to observe
non-judgmentally what goes on inside you
there is awareness there needs to be
awareness so that is
self
-knowledge is there some type of
discipline that is needed to be
successful with conscious manifestation
if so can you describe or the discipline
is that is needed
[Music]
well basically I have already described
the discipline that's needed for in your
daily life
to be a to be aware of yourself and of
your own state of consciousness
uh
also an important factor perhaps that is
implied in what we've been saying but
it's worth pointing it out
explicitly
is the importance of
what is conventionally called
gratitude
but there could be other words
gratitude is a very powerful
transformational tool and also one of
the most powerful
tools for manifesting
better things in your life
now what does that mean the Gratitude is
to to acknowledge
the good in your life now
and you it's surprising
how many people don't do that
who can only see the bad in their lives
or only complain but it's extremely
powerful to acknowledge the goods that's
in your life now the ability to think of
course was a wonderful evolutionary
achievement
it is associated also it's linked to the
development of language too so gradually
humans develop the ability to think and
it was a wonderful evolutionary
evolutionary advance
but over the over many many Millennia
the the thinking activity began to take
over and so most human beings these days
actually never stop thinking so what
they experience is what I call a voice
in the head
which is the internal dialogue that most
people uh experience experience
throughout the day during their waking
hours
there's this continuous inner dialogue
taking place monologue dialogue whatever
you want to call it there's a there's a
commentator in the in your mind that
interprets immediately and judges
situations and people and and things
it spends much more time thinking about
some other moment rather than this one
and usually it's the future and and some
people of course dwell excessively on
the past too they carry around the
burden of past in their minds and in and
in their emotional field without knowing
it without realizing that it doesn't
have to be that way without realizing
that they are allowing the past which
after all is only certain thoughts that
they carry in the head they're allowing
the past to uh to sabotage their whole
life they're carrying such a burden of
past that they can no longer experience
the present so you either burdened by
the past or you're buried by the future
now the question of why is very
important what what is the ultimate
cause of this and that is the what one
could call overthinking
thinking was a wonderful thing and still
is a wonderful thing but it has taken
over human beings it has
proliferated to such an extent that now
thinking has become almost a
a
parasitical entity that lives in your in
your head that won't leave you alone
you know
most people's sense of identity most
people sense of who they are is
bound up with their mind activity with
their thinking so they derive their
sense of self from certain stories that
they're telling themselves
in their mind and that's to do with what
happened in the past what other people
did to you things you identify with that
these are
thoughts things that belong to me these
are my things these are all thought
formations
so people identify with the voice in the
head
and the voice in the head
becomes
a
for them impossible to to distinguish
from who they are
so they talk to themselves in that you
everybody has met people in the street
who
talk themselves out aloud and usually
people look at them say oh there's a
crazy person going
but virtually everybody does that except
that they don't do it out loud if you
could listen into when if you look walk
around in this city if you could listen
to to but what's going on in people's
heads you would realize they're all
talking to themselves a lot of chatter
yes and they are so identified with it
that they they kind of they are it the
voice has taken you over the the the the
Mind activity the conceptual mind has
taken you over and then it becomes
virtually becomes you so in that state
which in spiritual terms we call
unconscious when we use the word
unconscious in in spiritual terms right
it does not have the same meaning as as
it has in conventional terms usually
when we use unconscious in conventional
terms we're talking about somebody who
is just dropped off but he's unconscious
when we use the word unconscious in
spiritual terms it means it refers to
somebody who is totally identified with
the stream the consent continuous stream
of thinking which is conditioned by the
past the types of thoughts that you
think the stories that you continuously
revive in your head
uh have been conditioned by your past in
the past of the culture that you grew up
in the country you grew up in all the
things that make up your past your
personal past and the collective Paths
of your
environment so a person who grew up in
let's say Saudi Arabia will not be
thinking the same kind of stories and
will not interpret the world in the same
way as somebody who grew up in Canada or
in the west but what they have in common
they are both identified with the
continuous stream of think they may be
different stories there may be a
different sense of identity but but in
both cases they are they they cannot
they cannot separate themselves from The
Voice in the head I haven't gone through
physical death yet it
as the
zen master who was asked
about
life after death
said I don't know
and they said why don't you know you're
the master
and he said yeah but I'm not a dead
master
[Music]
but I've gone very deeply to what one
could call death to identification with
form
so in a way I have gone into that Realm
from where I can say and know that
ultimately what we see as death
is the dissolution of form that the
Eternal in US
which I know that first hand cannot be
touched by that so
what exactly happens
I would say depends on
whatever state of consciousness
you were in that was be a predominant
State of Consciousness in this lifetime
if in this lifetime
you were continuously identified with
form
your body
or the psychological form of me
that means Consciousness this expression
of consciousness
was still in a somewhat dreamlike state
which is identification with form
and
you can easily extrapolate from that if
the tendency of Consciousness to
identify with form was still there which
in other ways The Awakening had not
happened
this tendency will continue there will
be further identification with form and
the process will continue as the
Consciousness that is not yet fully
awake
will continue to identify with form
again
and then gradually come to a place where
Awakening happens or if
there has already been a
disidentification from form in this
lifetime
then you can extrapolate from there that
the compulsive urge to identify with
form and to seek another
form or another cycle of form
identification
this compulsion to seek further
experiences through through identifying
with form
then would either be much weaker
or be completely absent
in which case the Consciousness that you
are
is no longer bound
to
this realm and will not seek to
re-experience the realm of form
but in either case
you really
I know I can tell you that all is well
does not really matter whether
this person
now needs further
experiences of identification in which
case this will happen
or whether he is already
free of this urge in which case
he will move on and
live in a realm that we can't even
conceive of
from where we are here I get a sense
deep within in the forms of what that is
but we don't need to talk about it here
all we know is
nothing
this is the beginning of the Course in
Miracles
which is the entire course in Miracle
summarized in two lines
nothing real can be threatened
nothing unreal exists
herein lies the peace of God
that which is real in him is beyond form
anybody can know that when you see a
dead body you realize that this is no
longer whom you knew this is not the
this is not the being that you knew this
is only a shell
so nothing real can be threatened
nothing unreal ultimately exists
this is why
sages from all Traditions speak of this
realm of form is ultimately illusory It
ultimately it depends what level you
look at
the important thing is
all is well beyond the appearance on the
level of form which is the only level
where deaths exists it is the transition
from from one form
into another form or from one form into
formlessness
that is what death is no more than that
nothing real dies nothing real dies
which is to say ultimately
there is no such thing as death there
only seems to be it's a transmutation of
form either form dissolves or seek some
other form some other identification
with form they are inner state
does not have to be totally determined
by external conditions you're not at the
mercy any longer of external conditions
which means for example also people some
people are I mean people are very
problematic people people
so proud summer is rude to you or
somebody fails to do something that they
should do or should have done all kinds
of things that you can complain about in
people's behavior
and a lot of the complaining that one
does about other people is totally
futile it does not change them because
you you when you talk to others about
them you say well do you know what he
did and then he said and I only did that
oh my God he did that or you do it in
your head
it's all futile it does not change that
person
so
uh if somebody is rude to you like oh
it's he doesn't you're carrying yourself
or the supermarket carrying your
shopping and somebody slams a dirt or on
your face because it doesn't it's rude
for many people there the triggers can
trigger a train of negative thoughts
that lasts for the next 10 15 or 20
minutes
so that means and if you're completely
identified with the stream of thinking
you don't even know you think you're now
experiencing a bad reality you do you
because you have not a stakenness you
have not taken a step back from your
thinking you have not become aware of
your thinking you are so in your
thoughts that you are totally identified
with the thoughts so the the key then is
to to uh
be able to separate your your mental
interpretation of things from the
Simplicity of the isness of the present
moment so you don't add unnecessary
suffering to situations you no longer
create unnecessary suffering for
yourself
because you realize
the unhappiness that you're experiencing
in a given situation in 90 percent of
the cases is not produced
by the situation it is produced by the
way in which your mind
tells a story about the situation our
purpose here beyond the personal
purposes that we have everybody has
their personal purpose the work you do
or whatever it is
there's a deeper purpose that the
personal purpose must be aligned with
and that deeper purpose is to live from
that deeper place
uh the way I interpret you know in the
English language doesn't have a word
that describes both men and women it's
the German language has Mensch which is
also used in Yiddish to the German has
managed means both man or woman for a
long time I regretted that the English
language doesn't have a word for human
you have to say human being but now I'm
happy that I have to say human being
because that describes exactly the two
Dimensions the human is the conditioned
self it's a personality your historical
person which comes from the past based
on past who you are as a person that
includes your physical body and your
psychological self I call that sometimes
your form identity there's a physical
form and there's a psychological form of
you that's the human
and then there's a being the being is
the Deeper Self that is consciousness
unconditioned and no human life is
fulfilled unless the human has at least
some access
to this Dimension within them that
really is the ultimate purpose to at
least
maybe not complete access but at least
you have glimpses of that which
transcends the self to have glimpses of
self-transcendence in your life if you
no matter how successful you are in this
world
if you have never had even a glimpse of
self-transcendence then your life is
pretty purposeless and and it's very
unlikely that you will be a happy human
being
is is the ultimate Paradox with all of
this that it's almost impossible to hold
on to so even someone that has spent
their life uh trying to attain that
State uh that you can't a you can't you
to function it as a human maybe not as a
human being but just as a human uh it
would be almost impossible to constantly
be in that state in a world that doesn't
exist in that state yes not constantly
but it is possible to uh to to to not
just have that when you are perhaps
let's say engaged in spiritual practice
or you're meditating or when you're out
in nature and some happy moments out in
nature it it is our task to as much as
possible
incorporate that deeper level of
Consciousness into our daily life even
if we don't succeed all the time and
that's fine that's part of the practice
so one could say then our purpose in our
daily life beyond the personal purpose
which is also important because we need
to honor
who we are as a person to and we need to
honor our identity as a person because
no doubtedly that exists and whatever it
is that makes up your identity whether
it's mostly personal kind whether you
identify with a concern a collective
around you it could be your religion it
could whatever it might be
or the culture that you grow up in that
has its place that there's nothing wrong
with it but if that is all you know
about yourself that's very limiting so
you honor it but there's more to you
than that
and that's why the ancient Greeks said
starting from Pythagoras
500 BC
know thyself the most perhaps the most
important victim in ancient Greek
philosophy which was carved cuffed on
the walls of the Temple of Apollo at
Delphi know thyself very deep saying
know who you are in your essence
so because you have the form identity
which is a personality the fall and you
hasn't have as I call it an Essence
identity and so to know yourself at this
Essence is it called in in Indian some
in some Indian Indian spiritual
philosophy is called self-realization I
have the main focus of your attention
in your daily life
in the present moment
the rest of your attentions of that
scene from the main focus here is this
the rest of your attention is
where you want to go to your whatever
task you're engaged in has a certain
purpose
the purpose is you want to finish the
task then it has achieved its purpose
and that's here
and that's in the in your peripheral the
peripheral vision of your Consciousness
that's where you want to get to
and this is what you're doing in order
to get there
and your main attention is not
where you want to get and in the
meantime you're just doing it in order
to get there you can see how that's
already creates an inner stress
I'm here but I want to be there
that's a normal way of living is
the main part of people's attention is
there but in the meantime they are here
where they don't really want to be
rather be there
at as shown in the famous
stickers on bumper stickers on cars
which say something like I'd rather be
fishing the sense of being an outsider
is also something that
I have had
throughout my life
and
the sense of
not belonging here
watching my parents
being engaged
in continuous
conflict
not because there were bad people they
were they did what they did and they
loved me as best they could
and they did what they did
as a reflection of their state of
consciousness at that time which was a
normal State of Consciousness egoic
state of consciousness
but I sometimes felt how did I get here
somehow didn't there must have been a
mistake
um
it's often
Outsiders
is being feeling an outsider on the one
hand is seems a terrible limitation that
you can't participate
as much but on the other hand it's a
great opportunity because
some of the most creative people
uh in the world have what have been
Outsiders they did not fit in
uh Misfits it's the English word Misfits
um
another the friendships I had
when I was a child
that's another interesting thing I had
to
friend one of my friends was it was
severely
physically
disabled
and nobody else wanted to
be friends with him because of that and
he was
probably my closest friend
and the other one was so weird that
nobody wanted to talk to him
uh but he became my friend so they were
Outsiders too
and
dot but the interesting fact here as you
know I couldn't believe it when they
told me
that there are people here from 70
countries it seems almost unbelievable
that's true I saw the list
70 countries
and you may find I'm sure you will find
quite often
uh you you you can feel a bond or you
have you have more in common
with many of the people who are here
then you have with your own people in
your own country at home who are not
going through any Spiritual Awakening
who are still totally conditioned 100
conditioned by their culture so you feel
a connectedness here with other humans
that transcends culture and conditioning
and all this silly political stuff it
transcends that and this is a wonderful
thing so to some extent you can now
connect with people even if you don't
always see them physically where you
might live I don't know whether you live
in a big city or a small village
a small City small small City yeah yeah
what city uh in Spock in Austria oh yes
yeah nice very nice
uh I don't know how many people in
Innsbruck are 120
000. and how many of those are Awakening
we don't know
we don't know of course but this helps I
believe being here and feeling You Are
Not Alone
you are connected
so this would be helped for the rest you
just have to accept that this is how it
is and no matter how hard you try to fit
in on the normal level you probably
won't nor do you have to so I know this
there are many people here who feel that
and be happy with it but don't make it
into some kind of superiority because
the ego can always creep in
before you know it there's always a back
door and then the ego is back in so you
can you could go from feeling bad about
being an outsider to suddenly feeling
okay I'm an outsider because I'm
superior
and then so to have to be careful and
don't go there so
um
that's just how it is if you you
probably would not be here
if you had not been an outfelt like an
outsider for many years so it worked
certain actions take place you do things
you know
they're not
the optimal things to do but you can't
help it it's something
acts through you
um there's there seems to be some power
there that makes you do things
but you know no I'm not right or not
good for you and yet you can't stop it
that seems to be the case
um
and that of course
is often the case with people who are
with you it might be many different
different areas of your life but
um
this is also the case with addictions
for example people are addicted to a
certain substance or who are addicted to
eating too much or drinking
there's something that overpowers them
in you that seems to obscure
the awareness
or the awareness is pushed to recite and
this thinking this this powerful thing
does it anyway
and again my answer is a little bit
similar to
um
what I say to the first question uh
tonight
the
the power of the presence
needs to grow in you so that
it is strong enough not to it's not
willpower because willpower is not
the best way of dealing with these
things but
it's what I'm talking about could
sometimes be confused with willpower but
willpower includes the application of a
force to hold something down let's say
um
if your addiction is to
um have a to indulge in
intoxicating beverages in other words
booze is the British word then
and you can feel it it comes on there it
comes you know the bottles are there
there they are and you feel you have to
go then you have to reach out and you
have to pour yourself a drink now
when you're not aware at all you don't
even know what you're doing you're so
unconscious that you you're already
holding the drink and you're drinking
then you at that point you you even know
that you're drinking uh the same with
food I've spoken to people who've had
addictions to food they often say they
wake up when they're ready they've
already eaten in the middle of the night
they've already unconsciously gone to
the fridge taking out the chocolate cake
and then they're already halfway through
the chocolate cake and suddenly what am
I doing
but so awareness comes in at a very late
point
willpower would be to hold an urge down
let's say I'll go they have to pull or
even what's the example you gave you
want to turn on the TV and you know it
it's not right because I I'm not here
for that and he actually told us not to
do it
help it I have to go I can't I can't no
willpower you would you would say I'm
going to hold this I'm not going to do
it
and I can confirm the odds but you're
holding it down
[Laughter]
um when you hold things down
often after a while
an explosion happens it's like a boiling
kettle
can't hold it for that long and then you
have some kind of rationalization in
your mind but it's you'll do it anyway
the mind will give you a reason first
you see the need to be a victim identity
also unfortunately is a form of ego
because any conceptual identity is a
form of ego and even though you seem to
be amp is Justified in having a victim
identity because of the things that
other humans did to you you yourself are
finding yes you are finding yourself in
a kind of prison
that created by your mind
so there's no denial of that bad things
happen to you yes
now question is
how do you exit this mental present
the first step is perhaps to see
um
that
unconscious human beings
unconscious human beings in the grip of
their own conditioning their own ego
they have virtually no free will
when you are unconscious you are
controlled by
the the called Mind patterns that are
lodged in your psyche
you have you cannot really speak of Free
Will by somebody who has zero awareness
and yet the entire makeup is
conditioning from the past
so
the famous sentence phrase used by Jesus
in connection with forgiveness on the
cross he said forgive them for they know
not what they do
now these these two interesting these
points put together
forgive them why forgive them
they know not what they do in other
words if he had spoken these days using
our terminology
he probably would have said they are
completely unconscious
because that's what it means they know
not what they do they are completely
unconscious
so when you see nobody can act beyond
their level of consciousness
then you see that it's almost like it
becomes almost like the evil that was
perpetrated it becomes almost like a
natural phenomenon
that is like you've been hit by
lightning or something or
lived in very unpleasant
climatic conditions that could injured
you
near volcano
and my dad what had problems with anger
huge the outbursts of anger quite
frequently it was living like living the
legs to a volcano that could erupt at
any moment
um
and he could not help it it was it was
impossible there was no possibility of
being different
and so these humans are run by
unconscious conditioning usually goes
back to their childhood and what
happened there
I know why my father was angry I I
needed I realized much later that it all
originated in his childhood the the
reasons why he was so angry and also
for a while also I felt a resentment
towards that and only when I was able to
awaken out of egoic consciousness
I saw that there's nothing that he could
have done differently because there
wasn't enough awareness
now
when you see that then you don't
personalize or you don't create an
identity for other humans out of their
unconsciousness because in essence
that's not who they are the recognition
that their first recognition then step
one you recognize that no human can act
beyond their conditioning
in the absence of awareness
if there's awareness they can transcend
their conditioning and then they begin
to become conscious of their own
conditioned mental emotional
dysfunctional mental emotional patterns
yes
so they couldn't
they can't help it so that's that's
already a useful step in forgiveness but
it you may not yet be able to arrive at
at full forgiveness because of that
another before I continue with that
does that mean then a question may arise
in your mind
doesn't mean then humans are not really
responsible for what they do
if they are unconscious how are they
responding does that mean then that we
shouldn't punish them from what they do
if they commit a crime
are they not guilty
that's an interesting question
the the unconsciousness
that operate inhuman even if you are
able to forgive a human when we come we
will go more fully into that in a minute
even if you are able to forgive and
human for their transgressions or
whatever they did
this does not mean and even though the
human is not responsible for their
unconsciousness and yet
it is built into the structure of human
life
they still need to suffer the
consequences of their unconsciousness
usually happiness exists as part of the
play of opposites you experience the
happiness because something makes you
happy
and then that thing that made you happy
either leaves you or the very thing that
made you happy suddenly makes you
unhappy
marriage for example
[Music]
relationship
before you start living together you're
happy when you start living together
you're unhappy
so what is if it's not happy what are we
talking about the
there's a
if you
let go of thinking and remain as the
awareness
then there is in that that awareness
emanates a certain
peace alive
peace
Joy peace a peaceful
joyful sense of aliveness
in a piece may be a better word than
happiness
but Mom would have to add to it
it's an alive piece it's not the Peace
of having deadened yourself through
emotions
or anything like that it's an alive
intensely alive piece you can sense it
even if it's only just a glimpse right
now
surrender thought
and of course
right now if you're not thinking
about the problems of your life
there are no problems in this moment
there's only a sense of beingness or
liveness
and that is the connectedness with being
and so you transcend the Opposites
between happiness and unhappiness when
the Buddha was teaching 2500 years ago
he told people
to seek out a quiet place in the forest
and meditate there
that was an essential part of his
teaching
so nature was an essential part of his
and of course as you know probably The
Story Goes that
the Buddha said
under a tree
when as The Story Goes he awakened
spiritually or became enlightened so his
enlightenment
is associated
with that tree
a tree
don't believe what science tells you
there's more to the tree than that
and you can know that and sense that
if you become still enough and give it
your attention
looking
almost
sensing its Stillness
sure
but it is a reciprocal movement it goes
both ways
yes nature becomes conscious
of itself through you
but nature also
helps you
to realign yourself
with Stillness I am is the word
all you can say is I am
but you don't need you don't add
anything not this or that
I am
in the Old Testament
God has asked who are you
then that's perhaps the most profound
sentence in the Old Testament is I am
that I am
where God defines him her itself
as the I am as the essence identity of
all forms
and also another beautiful
sentence in the Old Testament as you
know the Old Testament is a mixed the
notice the Bible is a mixed bag of
fantastic things and other things
the
but I like to look for the jewels that
are there
another beautiful statement that points
to all this is
be still and know that I am God
now these words
are all synonymous
be
refers to being
still is a state of consciousness
without thought Stillness
being and Stillness is the same thing
and no
there is a deep knowing in that in fact
it's that is because that is the source
of all
intelligence there's a deep knowing
but from the point of view of the
conceptual mind
it looks like
unknowing it looks like ignorance
because it's not knowing through
Concepts anymore it's there's a deeper
knowing and this is where what we call
wisdom arises which is very different
from intelligence the IQ kind of
intelligence
the wisdom that the world needs not more
please no
but wisdom
that yes
be still and know that I am
it is the I am of the the I am of being
God
oh here we come to a difficult word
but they're all synonymous
what is God then
I rarely talk about God because you
can't really it's so Transcendent that
whatever you say would be very limited
as you know human language and human
sword is relatively limited how can I
make statements about the ultimate
Transcendent reality
just by producing a few weird sounds
with my vocal cords
Plus
air pressure through my tongue and lips
all the vowels a i a e i o u e uh
this is what the language is
okay now tell me the ultimate secrets of
God in the Transcendent Universe
it's upset
just produce a few sounds and that
explains no however I'll carry on
talking
[Music]
all we can do is give a an analogy or
like a poetic image of what God might be
and how God relates
to who you are
and that image is I that I prefer
is the image of in of our you know we
can only use images from our sense
perceived universe
the sun is a life-giving thing in our
universe the sun gives of itself
ceaselessly for millions and millions of
years one could almost say
eternally it's not Eternal but as far as
we are concerned it's Eternal without
the sun there would be no life no
physical life here so the son gives off
itself it emanates continuously uh the
very heat in your body ultimately comes
from the Sun so the sun if you use the
Sun as an analogy for for the the
transcendent
Universe the Transcendent God
has no location in space or time God is
neither there or if we have to say
anything we could say God is right here
because it's Transcendent to this
dimension
so if we use this as an analogy the the
Transcendent emanates into this
Dimension something that creates
form that creates life and what It
ultimately this thing that it emanates
is consciousness at first very little at
first Consciousness appears as as it
were frozen as minerals and stones and
then Consciousness becomes as if it were
liquid if we use energy of water then it
becomes vegetative life then again
Consciousness gradually evolves so one
Consciousness more of it comes in then
you get animal life it's like and then
you get human life it becomes ethereal
it's a human mind
emanating from the source of all life
that is transcendent of which you cannot
say anything
into this world as the sun emanates
light
the god emanates Consciousness and this
brings about this universe and in this
universe it's a process it grows
in the transcendent
we don't know anything about that so
not the important thing is
the ray of sunlight that you come that
hits your hand you feel the warmth on
your hand
that Ray it's not the sun we couldn't
say I have the sun on my hand I mean if
you got close to the Sun you would
immediately disappear but this Ray of
sunlight is still connected to the sun
in some way it is still part of the sun
we can't even say where the sun exactly
ends it doesn't really end anywhere it
doesn't have a clearly defined surface
it extends outward
so it emanates continuously
so what the what the source of all life
emanates is consciousness
and you can sense that
in yourself
when you can sense
yourself as Consciousness the presence
then you are then you realize this the
Ripple on the surface of the ocean
has realized
that it is not only a ripple I'm mixing
analogies now
it's not only a ripple more
fundamentally the Ripple is the ocean
and suddenly the Ripple is no longer no
longer fearful
because it can sense its deep
connectedness
to that which is vast and
all-encompassing
and so the ripples only
lives in a different way because it
realizes
its own Timeless essence
or the Sun the ray of sunlight could do
the same it could suddenly become aware
that it is still connected and part of
the sun it can and you can sense in
yourself
the undoubted fact that you are
conscious
but not only that
we're creating a duality here that
doesn't exist when we say that you are
conscious
the essence of who you are is
consciousness so you are Consciousness
be aware of the
conceptualizing your life
and allowing
an unhappy story
in your head
to make you unhappy
people think they are unhappy because of
the circumstances of their lives
in most cases the unhappy because of
what they are telling themselves or what
the mind is saying about
what's going on around you and has
happened will happen
so that's a it's a suffering the origin
of suffering to a large extent is there
and even in extreme situations having
lost your home for example
not knowing where to live
even there it applies
you do not in the face of a challenge
if you are present
you don't convert the challenge into
suffering
you just
be with what is
and you start experimenting with little
things in your life that cause you
irritation
or a little bit of anger
or some impatience
lit situations that are very common
every day
and you look at the situation you become
aware sadly that there's irritational
writing or anger Rising
and you become aware that it doesn't
actually feel very good and the body
knows it doesn't feel good the body
doesn't like it
there's irritation arising and you think
it's because of what's going on but if
you look more closely think now is this
situation causing this
or is what I'm saying about it causing
this what my mind the commentary of my
mind
and in most cases you will find it's the
mental commentary that you had been
identified with that causes the
unhappiness
and then you say let's experiment with
removing the commentary how would I
experience this situation if I did not
ADD the mental baggage to it
thank you
so in other words you're just now with
the isness of this moment
without any thing mental stuff added
being added to it that says this should
not be happening I don't want to be here
and many other things
suddenly
you're fine
a minute ago
you were extremely air irritated and
angry
and you couldn't differentiate between
the circumstances
external sanctions of your life and the
inner commentary about the circumstances
and this is the essence of
unconsciousness
unable to differentiate between the
circumstances and the commentary
so the circumstances and the commentary
becomes single ethics are experienced as
a single phenomenon
and then when you suddenly you can
separate this is the isness of this
moment
and it is as it is
the enormous power is suddenly arising
in you which is the power of the present
moment which is The Power Of
unconditioned Consciousness also the
power of dealing with the situation if
there's something that you need to do
suddenly the right action as the Buddha
calls it the right action happens
or non-action if action is not possible
then right surrender happens
but you allow this moment to be as it is
without but what does it mean means you
don't add unnecessary mental baggage to
it that argues through the is-ness of
this moment oh yeah there may be one or
two people
being with us here
there
who perhaps are stuck somewhere in a
room and can't get out because of
physical disability or they may be in
prison
and they say what can I do what can we
do we can't get out into nature
well you need to remember that your body
also is nature
so you can start there
every time you take a breath
that's nature nature is breathing the
air that you're breathing is nature
the very fact of breathing is a natural
process
it's not choice
it's done for you it's not so much that
you praise although we say I breathe
but you're not the body breathing so
it's a natural thing that happens you
wouldn't say I'm beating my heart you
don't do that but that's the same thing
the body does it it's a natural process
for some reason we say I'm breathing
because breathing is semi voluntary
you can't stop it for a while
but not for that long because if you
stop it for too long nature takes over
and you go
so nature takes as nature you live with
nature with your body
so even if you can't get out you can
start by being aware of that level of
yourself
the the physical level
the natural part of Who You Are
the body and not just by saying okay
I'm looking at my hands or my feet not
just the physic not the external image
of the body
but you can go into the body with your
attention
and that's your nature
even if you're in a present sale you can
do that
and even if there's no opportunity you
might be in an office Block in Manhattan
and you look out of the window and all
you have is maybe a little bit of sky
okay there's a little bit of nature
there you can look at that
but you have more nature than that in
yourself so as you sat in your office
wherever it is
go within first be conscious that
breathing is happening
the body's breathing
be conscious also of the the
preciousness of the air
it's such a precious substance
so to acknowledge that
is actually part of what sometimes is
called to live in a state of
gratitude
now some people say what can I be
grateful for there's nothing in my life
that I can be grateful for well are you
breathing
yes well you start there is religion
necessary it depends who you are on the
level of the farm for some people it can
be necessary or helpful
for two reasons
it can provide the more superficial
reason
it can give your life a certain amount
of structure which for some people can
be helpful
regular practice
gives you a feeling of comfort
some people have too little structure in
their lives and others have too much
already
if you have too little structure in your
life then religion can provide
that
more importantly on another level
religion can either obscure
the
spiritual Dimension within yourself and
often it does
or
if used rightly if approached rightly if
understood
on a deeper level
it can
help you
access and stay in connectedness
with that deeper level of yourself or
the Transcendent dimension of
consciousness
whether or not you need it only you can
know whether you find it either helpful
or a hindrance
we can be either depend depends on
you as a person your past what function
it had in your past
and so on
it is a hindrance
if religion becomes an ideology
then it operates only on the level of
the Mind
and it's very similar to any other kind
of ideology that you may believe in
whether it's uh
communism as a as an ideology or any
political theory of anything that
explains the universe it could be a
metaphysical system that you completely
believe in
philosophical system and so on
so an ideology is something that takes
possession of your mind
and exerts a controlling function
and it can influence
almost your entire mental functioning if
it becomes something of
overwhelming power in your mind it's a
it's a little thought that grows into a
huge thing in your mind and the
tentacles breeds into every aspect of
your mind and there are religious people
like that
usually you can recognize that it is an
ideology
by the fact that they are not peaceful
human beings
and by the fact that
they have
enemies
either even within their own religion
or another religion anybody who does not
agree with their ideology
becomes an enemy in the same way the
people who were not nowadays that many
were deeply believing in communism which
was a wonderful idea to start with of
course
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions it was a beautiful idea of
equality
everybody the same that is wonderful no
personal possessions it's wonderful too
and the only mistake was
it was imposed from outside by people
who themselves has not gone beyond the
egoic State of Consciousness they just
played it in their mind isn't that's a
good idea
and then it was imposed on on other
people who also were not in that state
of consciousness but most importantly
those who impose the idea on others
forced them to live it out
the idea became contaminated with ego
so when these people came to power
the egos
became inflated to an enormous degree
almost to absurdity and without
realizing it
they
uh
re-enacted
the same
evils in in some cases worse than those
that they were fighting against
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Bruce Lipton inspiration
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there one of the things
that really upset me for a long time was
the fact that I had great ideas and
intentions and I wanted to manifest them
and I thought this is how it's going to
manifest and so I had all these visions
of how things were going to unfold and
then I'd started processing it wouldn't
unfold